ON PUBLIC SAFETY WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO CALL WITH NINETEEN AND
MARTIN SHE AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS TO
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE MEMBERS
TO THE PUBLIC PUBLIC. TWO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALL ALL AND WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISHED TO TESTIFY TODAY.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL NOT SIT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANTS WHAT- NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX.
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY TWO. THAT'S.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO. SIX
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY TWO AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN FIVE NINE
TWO SEVEN FOUR THREE ONCE AGAIN
THAT. SEVEN FIVE NINE TWO SEVEN
FOUR THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE WAR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE WILL MOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT AND WHEN WE
MOVE I SHOULD SAY THE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BILL SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LONG
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE KNOW THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE FALL. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR YOU IT
FROM YOU AND WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE THE HEARING ALL
IN ALL BILLS ON OUR SCHEDULE.
AFTER THE INITIAL WITNESSES. OF
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE WILL
BE LIMIT PUBLIC COMMENT TO
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN MINUTES PER
SIDE. I WILL MAIN MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE MEETING
SERVICES ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED OR REMOVED
FROM CHAMBER. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. AND
IT'S CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS CUSTOMARY THERE WILL BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT
SO ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
BE HEARD. SO TODAY WE HAVE NINE
BILLS ONE OF WHICH HAS BEEN
PULLED ANOTHER WHICH IS- AB.
TWO FIVE THREE BY- SOME
MOVEMENT PATTERNS PATTERSON AND
ONE ON CONSENT AB SIX SEVEN
THREE BY SOME WOMEN CONSERVE
OUR- A SALAS. BEFORE
PRESENTATIONS BEGAN OR WHAT CAN
WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM. CANCEL
PLEASE CALL ROLE BRADFORD
PRESIDENT OF BRADFORD PRESENT A
CHOI BOGUE PRESIDENT OBAMA
PRESENT KAMLAGER HERE KAMAGRA
HERE TO CAMPUS SKINNER WINNER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO SEE IF WE CAN GET
A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SOME RECALL MARDER. COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONCERN GALLAGHER AP SIX SEVEN
THREE BRADFORD. HI BRADFORD AYE
pGUY COM LOGGER HI I'M LONGER
AYE SKINNER WIENER THE MEASURES
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE- THAT
ITEM OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SAT ON. OKAY NOW- WE
HAVE OUR FIRST AUTHORED THE
PRESIDENT- ASSUMING. JONES
SAWYER ANNE'S PRESENTING A. B.
THREE THREE ONE SOME OF THEM
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
THREE THREE ONE WHICH EXTENDS
THE SUNSET PROVISION FOR THE
CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND THE OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
PROPERTY CRIMES TASK FORCE.
UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CRAFTED THE ORIGINAL BILL IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
SURE SURE THAT THIS LAW WOULD
BE TARGETING SOPHISTICATED
OPERATION AS OPPOSED TO
PERSONAL PEP OUT OF NECESSITY.
SINCE THEN THE CRIME OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT AND THE
C. H. P. TASK FORCE HAVE BEEN
A- DIFFERENT TOOLS AND BUSTING
RETAIL THEFT RINGS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. EVENAS RECENTLY AS
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR. THIS
BILL CONTINUES TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN CAPTAINING A
PERVASIVE PROBLEM AND
PRESERVING THE PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE IN PUBLIC SAFETY REFORMS.
AB THREE THREE ONE WILL ALLOW
US TO MAINTAIN A VITAL TOOL
THAT HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE IN
HELPING US COLLECTIVELY RECOVER
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND PUT A
STOP TO THESE ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME RINGS WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IS STEVE MCCARTHY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION MEMBERS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL.
WE ARE ONE PRIMARY WE ARE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THAT WE
WILL PROVIDE YOU THREE MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY MISTER CARTY MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS I'M STEVE MCARTY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. ONTAP IS HERE IN
THE COALITION GROUPS ON OUR
LETTER WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB THREE THIRTY ONE.
FIRST ONE EXTEND MY THANKS TO
THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
MEASURE AND FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE OF ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME. THE ISSUE OF ALL
OUR C. AS RECEIVED A LOT OF
MEDIA ATTENTION LATELY. BUT IN
REALITY IT'S BEEN A GROWING
PROBLEM FOR MANY YEARS.
ORGANIZED CRIME IS FIGURED OUT
HOW TO MONETIZE RETAIL STUFF AT
SCALE. COMING EVER MORE
SOPHISTICATED ABOUT IT. YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN VIDEOS ON THE NEWS A
WORKOUT WAS BEING FILLED WITH
STOLEN MERCHANDISE HIS RING TO
SET UP ELABORATE NETWORKS STEAL
GOODS FROM OUR STORES NONSENSE
THOSE ITEMS EITHER ON THE
INTERNET TRUTHFUL STOREFRONTS
OR OTHER MEANS. SOMETIMES THE
RECRUIT OTHERS TO COMMIT THESE
STEPS ON THEIR BEHALF.
INCLUDING YOU ALMOST THAN
OTHERS. PROFITS PROFITS FROM
OVERSEAS HAVE BEEN TRACED WITH
THE FINANCING OF DRUG SMUGGLING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND OTHER
SUCH ACTIVITIES. DISRUPTING
THESE NETWORKS REQUIRED
ORGANIZE RESPONSES. ORIGIN
DESTINATION CAN BE COMPLEX AND
TAKE MANY MONTHS- ACTIVITIES
OUT ACROSS COUNTY. COULD YOU IN
THE FUTURE ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME TASK FORCE YOU'RE
BEGINNING TO MAKE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE PROBLEM THE
SOURCE. A DEDICATED FORCE WITH
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL ATHORITY
LIKE CHP ALONG THE STATUTORY
TOOLS TO PROSECUTE AND
DISMANTLE THESE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ESSENTIAL IN COMBATING
ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME. THIS IS
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY ONE CHERISE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
EXTENSION OF THE TASK FORCE AS
WELL AS THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT STATUTE. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NOW WILL MOVE TO THE
CHAMBERS OR ANYONE IN FORTY TWO
OLD THREE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE ONE. IN NINETEEN
NINE AND OUR OVERFLOW ROOM OF.
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE THERE NO I SEE NO
ONE THERE NOW MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES WILLING- WANTING
TO- TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE ONE. THANK YOU AT
YOUR TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THREE ONE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. ONE SHERMAN PLACED BACK
INTO THE LINE WE YOUR LINE
NUMBER WILL BE ANNOUNCED WHEN
YOU'RE CHU IS UP. PLEASE PICK
UP YOUR HANDSET MAKE SURE YOUR
PHONE IS ON MUTE IT BEFORE YOU
TO PRESS ANY BUTTONS. ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL PEOPLE QUEUING UP.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE TWENTY
FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE. THE
MORNING AFTER ON BEHALF OF TECH
BACK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE
CALLER. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
WE'RE STILL SIGNING LINE
NUMBERS HERE WE GO WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THIRTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HI GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
MICHELLE THOMAS SHOPPERS ANY
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PINE
TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD. BALLERINA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE THREE ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE LINE TWENTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS REX W. HìNH
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. YOUR. MR
SURELY HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN DO
IT THIS TIME BUT RIGHT NOW WILL
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURES FOR
OPPOSITION I SEE THERE'S NO
LEAK WITNESS- AND OPPOSITION IS
THAT STILL CORRECT. OKAY NOW.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE AND FORTY
TWO- THREE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE THREE ONE SEEN NINE
NOW WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM A TWENTY FORTY I SHOULD
KNOW WHEN THERE AS WELL THOMAS
MODERATE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES INTO YOUR- WITNESSES
WERE. IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
THREE THREE ONE. THANK YOU AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE THREE
ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE A LINE CHEWING UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
ASSIGN A LINE NUMBER. GOOD LINE.
THIRTY TWO. THIRTY MISTER CHAIR
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION
CLARIFYING WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WASN'T ABLE TO JOIN
THE PREVIOUS GROUP BUT ONE
INDICATORS ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. PINE THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS CHASING SHELTER ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE'RE BACK
TO SUPPORT OKAY ALL RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. I
WILL ASK SHE CHECKED ALONG MORE
TIME AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE THREE
ONE. WHAT BEGAN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE THREE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. FINANCIAL A LOT
OF PEOPLE INTERESTED THE
CHILDREN ARE THERE ARE NO LINES
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
NOW WILL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS UP FOR THE AUTHOR AS
IT RELATES TO AB. THREE THREE
ONE. NO QUESTIONS JUST WANT TO
THANK HIM. FOR BRINGING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD THANK YOU. YEAH
ERIC WERE SEEKING A MOTION. ALL
RIGHT THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR COM LONGER WE HAVE A
TO PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
AB THREE THREE ONE. AB THREE
THREE ONE BRADFORD R. REDFORD
I'D ENJOY BOTH I SURE HOPE I
CALM LONGER. COME LONGER AT A
SKINNER AND WIENER. WIENER HI
THE MEASURE HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR APPS TO MEMBER GRADUATION
TO ST. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MEDIAN CHAIR. FIVE SHE WILL
MOVE NOW TO. AB FOUR NINETEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES. JUST
A LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING REAL
QUICK ANNA CONCERT WHERE DO YOU
CAN. MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB FOUR ONE
NINE UNDER CURRENT LAW
PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION ABOUT A VICTIM OR
WITNESS SUCH AS SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER BIRTHDATE EMPLOYED A
FIDGET SORRY COMPLETE
DEDICATION NUMBERS AND
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION AMONGST A
HOST OF OTHERS ARE NOT
PROTECTED DEFENDED OR THEIR
FAMILY COULD REQUEST AND
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION
WITHOUT A COURT ORDER. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE IN CASES
INVOLVING FRAUD OR THEFT WITH
THE CRIMINAL DISCOVERY MAY
INCLUDE A TREASURE TROVE OF
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION SUCH AS EMAIL
ACCOUNTS DATE OF BIRTH SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS BANK RECORDS
CREDIT CARDS DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND MANY MORE AB FOUR ONE NINE
IS A SIMPLE MEASURE TO PROTECT
CERTAIN TYPES OF PERSONALLY
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION THAT
CAN BE DISCLOSED TO A
DEFENDANT. IF SUCH INFORMATION
IS NEEDED BY THE DEFENSE TO
BUILD THE CASE THIS BILL KEEPS
CURRENT LAN TECH BY ALLOWING
THE COURTS REQUIRE THAT
INFORMATION BE GIVEN AB FOUR
ONE NINE HAS POTENTIAL TO HELP
GIVE VICTIMS AND WITNESSES OF
CRIMES THE PEACE OF MIND THAT
IF THEY COME FORWARD WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT A CASE THE
STATE CAN PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
THEM. THE BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF BAR
ASSOCIATIONS AND ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE TODAY VIA
PHONE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IS MICHAEL FOR AND ON BEHALF OF
THE SPONSOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU H. YOUR WHAT SURE SURE FOR
ANSWERING QUESTIONS OR YOU HAVE
THE PRESENTATION. BOTH PLEASE
OKAY ARMS FIRM WILL ALLOW YOU A
THREE MINUTE PRESENTATION ON AB
FOUR NINETEEN. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU CENTER
BACKWARD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FOR A BOARD MEMBER WITH THE
COPIES OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATION WHICH SEEKS TO
PROMOTE JUSTICE LAWS BY
BRINGING TOGETHER ATTORNEY
VOLUNTEERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE. TO IDENTIFY DEBATE AND
PROMOTE CREATIVE NONPARTISAN
CHANGES FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN THIS SPIRIT
THAT WE SUPPORT AB FOUR ONE
NINE AND SERVICE BILL SPONSORED.
UNDER EXISTING LAW BECAUSE
JURIES ARE ENTITLED TO RECEIVE
THE NAMES AND ADDRESSES OF
VICTIMS AND WITNESSES IN
ADDITION TO THE RIGHT WELL DID
STATEMENT. BUT THEY ARE
PREVENTED FROM DISCLOSING A BIT
THE MOMENTOUS IS ADDRESS OR
TELEPHONE NUMBER THIRD PARTIES
WITHOUT A COURT ORDER. IN AN
AGE OF DENTITY THEFT EIGHTY
FOUR ONE NINE. BUILT UPON
EXISTING LEGISLATIVE INTENT IN
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY AND WELL
BEING A VICTIM THE MINUTES
WITH. TO MAKE THE DECISION TO
FORGO THEIR ON ANONYMITY AND
REPORT FROM MARKETING. AB ONE
FOUR ONE NINE UPDATE EXISTING
LAW. PROTECTED DIGITAL FORMS OF
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION FROM ROUTINE
DISCLOSURE TO THIRD PARTIES.
DATE OF BIRTH SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS AND FINANCIAL ACCOUNT
INFORMATION. FORTY MILLION THE
CARD FOR CALIFORNIA MURATSUCHI
SHE IS PROUD OF THE COURT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. KNOW WILL
MOVE BACK TO THE ROOM HERE
FORTY TWO OLD THREE ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR NINETEEN. C. NINE WILL GO
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM- TWENTY
FORTY WE SEE NO ONE THERE AS
WELL. MODERATOR WILL NOW GO TO
PHONE LINES INTO THURS-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF FOUR
NINETEEN. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
FOUR NINETEEN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCHTONE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN SHOOTING UP. CURRENT WILL
GIVE MORE SECOND OR TWO. BE
SURE. ALL RIGHT AND NOW WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION AYE SHE
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION OF
RECORD- IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF FOUR NINETEEN
HERE AND FORTY TOOL THREE.
SCENE NINE AND WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY SIGNAL ON THERE AS
WELL MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES INTO YOUR-
WITNESSES- WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
NINETEEN. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FOUR NINETEEN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR WE HAVE
KNOWN INTO AT THIS TIME. IT
WOULD ANOTHER SECOND OR TWO.
ALL RIGHT DILLON AND YOU KNOW
ONE THING Q. ARE WE NOW BRING
IT TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FOR
THE AUTHOR OF A RELIGIOUS AB
PORTANTINO TWELFTH I RATE AND I
SEE THERE'S NONE- IT'S BEEN
PROPERLY MOVED BY CENTER
WIENER- SOON DAVIES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. IT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU OKAY. CANCERCARE
NEW CALL THE ROLL ON XP BEFORE.
NINETEEN WE HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AB FOUR
NINETEEN BRADFORD OUR FRIEND.
CHOI BOGUE I JOE BOAKAI COM
LONGER SKINNER WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE. THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS HERE
DON'T YOU HAVE THREE I'M SORRY.
AND HE OPENED UP TO GET OUT
COMMITTEE BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE TWO ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU TO HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU. WE'RE WAITING FOR AN
OFFER. WE ARE MARK SUPPER AB
FIVE OH SIX REPORT ON IN ORDER.
WE'RE HERE. SOME WOMAN
GONZALEZ- WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
CAN PRESENT AB FIVE OH SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE OH SIX WOULD
REQUIRE YOU SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS TO IMPLEMENT
SPECIFIED CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MEASURES AND REQUIRE
SPECIFIED VOLUNTEERS OF YOUTH
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS. THAT'S
IT IN PRINT TO BE MANDATED
REPORTERS- IN RECENT YEARS I AM
SEEN AS IN PRINT BECAUSE I'M-
GOING TO SUGGEST- AN AMENDMENT
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY- RELIEVE
THE STRESS OF THE NOW SAYS THAT
I FIND. INACCURATE BUT NONE THE
LESS WE CAN WORK ON THIS
TOGETHER- IN RECENT YEARS
INCREASE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
AND MEDIA ATTENTION HYTNER
WEIRDNESS OF CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ABUSE IN SCHOOLS CHURCHES
SPORTS TEAMS AND YOU SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS FOR INSTANCE OVER
NINETY THOUSAND CLAIMS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE HAVE
BEEN FILED AGAINST THE BOY
SCOUTS OF AMERICA EVIDENCE
SHOWED INTERNAL FILES TRACKING
IDENTITIES AND CRIMES OF
HUNDREDS OF PERPETRATORS WHO
WERE SCOUT LEADERS OR OTHER
ADULT VOLUNTEERS. HOWEVER
SUSPECTED ABUSE WITHIN THE BOY
SCOUTS WAS OFTEN NOT REPORTED
AN ORGANIZATION CONTINUALLY
FAILED TO MAKE MORE
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES SIMILARLY
OVER TWO HUNDRED CLAIMS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE WERE
FILED AGAINST THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB WHICH FAILED TO
REPORT ABUSE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND IN SOME CASES FAILED TO RUN
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON STAFF
DESPITE INTERNAL POLICIES TO DO
SO. MANY YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE ADOPTED INTERNAL BEST
PRACTICES THEY LACK UNIFORM
STANDARDS AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ADDITIONALLY THE ADULT
VOLUNTEERS WITH THE CLOSEST
CONTACT WITH YOUTH ARE OFTEN
NOT MANDY RICK REPORTERS ABOUT.
OF THE ABUSE AB FIVE OR SIX
WOULD CREATE BASIC MINIMUM
STANDARDS TO PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE NEWS ORGANIZATIONS. WOULD
INCLUDE BACKGROUND SCREENING.
REQUIRED TRAINING ON CHILD
ABUSE AND NEGLECT
IDENTIFICATION AND REPORTING
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION POLICIES SUCH
AS HAVING TO MANDATED REPORTERS
PRESENT WHEN CONTACT WITH
CHILDREN TOOK STEPS. TO THE
EXTENT FEASIBLE. AB FIVE OR SIX
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE SPECIFIED
REGULAR ADULT VOLUNTEERS WHO
HAVE DIRECT CONTACT OR
SUPERVISION CHILDREN BECOME
MANDATE REPORTERS. A SYSTEM
WHICH THE LEGISLATORS
CONTINUALLY AFFIRMED AS AN
IMPORTANT POLICY TO PREVENT
ABUSE AND ABUSE AND NEGLECT AT
THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE
OPPORTUNITY. BEFORE I GO TO MY-
MY WITNESSES I JUST I WANT TO
START BY ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CONCERNS BROUGHT UP. IN THE
ANALYSIS. AND BY WHAT IS
SUDDENLY OPPOSITION DESPITE NOT
HAVING ANY IN THE ASSEMBLY PASSING WITH BIPARTISAN
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT WE NOW HAVE-
APPARENTLY THE ACLU HAS DECIDED
THEY DON'T LIKE MANDATED
REPORTERS AND ALTHOUGH THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM DOES
OBVIOUSLY HAVE PROBLEMS THIS IS
A NEW POSITION AND SO I'M LEFT
TO TRY TO DEAL WITH A SEVEN
OPPOSITION AND SWELL OF
OPPOSITION THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO. GEN UP SO THIS IS WHAT. I'M
SUGGESTING WE DO WITH THIS BILL.
FOR NOW. CONTINUE TO REQUIRE
THE VOLUNTEERS WHO ARE. IN
CONTACT WITH CHILDREN BY FOR
EIGHT SIXTEEN HOURS PER MONTH
OR THIRTY TWO HOURS PER YEAR TO
TAKE THE TRAINING ON
IDENTIFYING CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT BUT NOT GIVE THEM THE
LEGAL MANDATE TO BE A MANDATORY
REPORTER MAKE THEM GO THROUGH
THE TRAINING SO THEY UNDERSTAND
BETTER HOW TO IDENTIFY AND ADDS
WE HOPEFULLY- ALLEVIATE THE-
CONCERNS. OF THE ACLU IN THE
FUTURE- PERHAPS REAP RETURNED
TO WHAT- THE RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE OR TO ANY KIND OF TRAINING
NECESSARY TO CREATE THE MANDATE
REPORTERS- WE WILL ACCEPT.
CONTINUE THE STRENGTHENING OF
THE BACKGROUND CHECK- UNDER
EIGHTY FIVE OH SIX THAT WAS AT.
IT SO IT WILL IT WILL APPLY AT
IT ASKS IN THE ANALYSIS WHO
APPLIES TO I THOUGHT IT WAS
PRETTY CLEAR ADMINISTRATORS
EMPLOYEES VOLUNTEERS WHO- ARE
IN DIRECT CONTACT WITH KIDS- WE
WILL- INSURE. HOPEFULLY WITH
THIS THAT A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION'S REMOVED DID THAT
MAKE SENSE I'M SORRY FOR
BRINGING THIS LAST MINUTE BUT
IT I WOULD WANT TO MAKE PEOPLE
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH REAP
ACTUALLY VOTING FOR IT AND
CONTINUING TO VOTE FOR IT-
WITHOUT. A TOTALLY GOT IN THE
BILL. YOUR NOT TAKING TO
SUGGEST AMENDMENTS THAT WE- A
FOURTH I DON'T THINK OF THOSE-
CUTTING THE BILL I JUST THINK
IT OUT FOR. BETTER
CLARIFICATION AGAIN HAVING-
BACKGROUND CHECKS- VIA THE
DEPARTMENT OF. JUSTICE AND
REDUCE THE SCOPE OF LAUNCHERS
ADDED AS A MANDATE REPORTERS-
THE FIRST AMENDMENT ABSOLUTELY
I'M ACTUALLY GOING FURTHER THAN
THE SECOND AMENDMENT. THE
SECOND AMENDMENT WOULD LIMIT
THE SCOPE TO VOLUNTEERS THAT
WEREN'T- DETENT VOLUNTEERS
BECOME MANDATE REPORTERS IF
THEY WEREN'T IN THE PRESENCE OF
ANOTHER MAN OF AN EMPLOYEE
THAT'S MANDATED REPORTER RATHER
THAN. THEN CREATE THAT TEAR IN
PEOPLE ARE STILL CONCERNED
ABOUT MAKING ADDITIONAL
MANDATED REPORTERS I SAID FINE
THEY WON'T BE MANDATED
REPORTERS BUT THEY WILL ALL
THESE VOLUNTEERS WILL HAVE TO
TAKE THE TRAINING. SURE WINNER
SCORED FROM. THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON A
MANDATED REPORTER ISSUE BUT
THAT'S A THAT'S A CLARIFICATION
SO IF YOU'RE A VOLUNTEER AND
YOU REPORT TO A MANDATED
REPORTER IS THAT ENOUGH THAT
YOU'RE NOT MANDATED OR IS IT
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE IN THE
PHYSICAL PRESENCE SO LET'S SAY
YOU'RE NO LONGER WILL BE
MANDATED REPORTERS WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS THE VOLUNTEERS WHO
SERVE. OVER- SIXTEEN HOURS. A
MONTH OR THIRTY TWO HOURS A
YEAR WILL HAVE TO BE TRAINED ON
HOW TO THAT TRAINING. GOT TO
TAKE ONE OF THE TRAINING ON
IDENTIFYING CHILD ABUSE NEGLECT
IN AND CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT. APPRECIATE YOUR
FLEXIBILITY ON THE- FOR NOW
THIS YEAR. I JUST WANT TO SAY
ALSO APPRECIATE BECAUSE YOU-
BURKE CRISTINA GARCIA GARCIA
BILL FROM LAST YEAR WHICH WE
ALL YOU SUPPORT WE SUPPORT IT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IN MANDATED
REPORTING- ELIMINATE SOME OF
THE INEQUITIES IN TERMS OF ALL
TO BE TO USE A THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THAT I THINK THAT
FIXED A BIG FLAW IN THE
MANDATED REPORTING SYSTEM. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. CENTERS SKINNER.
THANK YOU- CHAIR- I DON'T WANT
TO- SUPERSEDE THE CHAIR BUT IT
SEEMS SOUNDS LIKE WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS SUGGESTING MEETS THE
ANALYSIS WAS TRYING TO ACHIEVE-
I'M CLEAR ON WHAT SHE SUGGESTED
THAT OKAY SO- JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALL HAD THE SAME
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
AUTHOR WAS SUGGESTING. THANK
YOU. CENTER TROUBLED YOUR
QUESTION. JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY- THE NEW IMMENSELY CAME
THROUGH ART IF THEY COME AFTER
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON. THE NEW
THAT YOU'RE DRESSING TODAY
DON'T THE SCANNING- AND I'M
SORRY FOR ANY CONFUSION HI I AM
USED TO ASSEMBLY ANALYSIS WHICH
HAVE THE- REQUIRED AMENDMENTS
IN THE ANALYSIS SO I- WAS TOLD
THAT THE CONSULTANT DID NOT
WANT TO ACCEPT THEM AS
COMMITTEE ANALYSISPART
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ORIGINALLY
THAT WE HAD NEGOTIATED. AN
APPARENTLY THEY CAME THROUGH
YESTERDAY AS COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- AT THE SAME TIME IS
I WORKED WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND- SOME STAFF TO
US TO REDUCE THE- BILL IN OTHER
WAYS. DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
YEAH I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT EIGHT FIVE WHEN I SUPPORT
THE BILL I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
GOOD BILL IT'S MOVING FORWARD
ON THE RIGHT PROTECT ON THE
RIGHT PATH TO PROTECTING OUR
YOUTH THAT- I'M VOTING FOR WHAT
I THINK. WAS WHAT I AGREE TO.
AT THIS. STAGE IS WHAT MAKES
YOUR- MY UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT
THE CONSULTANT DID NOT WANT TO
OFFER UP AMENDMENTS BECAUSE
THEY THOUGHT THERE MIGHT BE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
I'M AS WE PRESENTED AND SO WE
WORKED ON AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
ANALYSIS. HELLO WHILE WE'RE
STILL HAVING DISCUSSIONS WILL
MOVE TO THE PREMIER WITNESSES
SUPPORT WILL GIVE EACH CHART
THREE MINUTES WE HAVE- SUPPORT
BY. DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ARE
THEY ON THE LINE YOU'RE A
PRIMARY WITNESS. MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP. THE
PRIMARY WITNESS AND SUPPORT
WILL GO WITH THEM THREE MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY. YES GOOD MORNING
SURE BRADFORD AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL MARTINEZ
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR HERE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. AS A SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL WE WOULD LIKE TO REALLY
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING
THIS MEASURE. ASSUMING AB FIVE
OH SIX THIS YEAR BECAUSE THE
PANDEMIC HAS MADE YOU FEEL MORE
ISOLATED THAN EVER MAKING THEM
GRAVITATE TO YOUTH SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS AS THEY TACKLE.
THEIR ANXIETY AND STRESS BUT
ALSO MAKING THEM MORE
VULNERABLE TO CHILD ABUSE.
PUBLICATION ACROSS OUR NATION
HAS ALSO SHED LIGHT ON CHILD
ABUSE THAT HAS OCCURRED IN
SCHOOLS CHURCHES SPORTS TEAMS
OUTDOOR SCOUTING CLUBS. AND
YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE OF
HOW YOUTH SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE DISTINCTLY STRUCTURED.
VOLUNTEERS ALONE ARE OFTEN THE
ONES SPENDING A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME WITH CHILDREN.
AB FIVE ZERO SIX OF THE BILL
NEEDED NOW. TO MANDATE OUR
STATE MANY YOUTH SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS TO IMPLEMENT
BASELINE CHILD ABUSE.
PREVENTION MEASURES INCLUDING
MANDATORY BACKGROUND CHECKS ON
ALL ADMINISTRATORS EMPLOYEES
AND VOLUNTEERS AS WELL AS THE
INCREASE TRAINING REPORTING AS
DESCRIBED BY OUR AUTHOR JUST
NOW. INCLUDING COMMISSIONER
LATTA BELIEVES THAT MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO PROTECT CHILDREN
FROM ABUSE AND NEGLECT. OUR
CONCERN THAT CHILD FATALITIES
CAUSED BY CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT HAVE DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGH NUMBERS FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHEN COMPARED TO THEIR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS. AND FOR
CHILDREN WHO DO SURVIVE AS WE
KNOW THE FACTS OF CHILD ABUSE
NEGLECT CAN LEAD TO A WIDE
RANGE OF ADVERSE OUTCOMES IN
ADULTHOOD. SURE A LOT OF LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
CONVERSATION AROUND
CALIFORNIA'S MANDATED CHILD
ABUSE REPORTING SYSTEM. AS IT
EXISTS TODAY SO THAT WE CAN
FURTHER PROTECT OUR CHILDREN
FROM ABUSE NEGLECT. PUTS OUT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE BACK TO
FORTY TWO OLD THREE IS THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE OH SIX PRESENT HERE. SHE
NINE WILL MOTOR OVERFLOW ROOM
OF TWENTY FORTY ANY WITNESSES
TO SUPPORT THEIR OF AB FIVE ALL
SIX AND SHE NO ONE. MODERATOR
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LAUNCH TO
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN Q. IN
SUPPORT OF. AB FIVE OH SIX. TO
VOICE SUPPORT OF AB FIVE OH SIX
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELL FIRST GO TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
TWENTY MINUTES CHEN REMEMBERS
FOR INSTRUMENTALISTS RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND THE
LOS ANGELES SCHOOL POLICE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU MCGEORGE. WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. WE'RE
PROVIDING THE LINE NUMBER AS WE
SPEAK ONE MOMENT PLEASE. HELLO.
YOUR TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY BEGIN AB FIVE OR SIX. YES I
WAS ALSO ONE OF THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
TODAY. OCT BEGAN THEM HE GOT.
OUR SO- GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
BOB YEAH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
FOUNDER OF THE CALIFORNIA BASED
NONPROFIT COALITION FOR
INSTITUTIONAL CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION I HOPE WITH SERVICE
THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR THE
CHILDREN CAUCUS I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE OH SIX AND
THE WIDE AFFIRMATIVE RESPONSES
TO THE PRIOR BILL TO PROTECT
BUSINESSES FROM ORGANIZED CRIME
AND PROTECT VICTIMS PRIVACY BUT
THIS BILL TO PROTECT CHILDREN
FROM BECOMING VICTIMS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. IT DIFFICULT FOR
ORGANIZATION UNDERSTAND WHY THE
AMENDMENTS ARE EVEN NECESSARY
THE FACT IS THAT 96% OF CHILD
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE INSTANCES
HAPPEN BY ABUSER KNOWN TO THE
CHILD ONLY HALF OF CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE CASES OCCURRED THE
MEDICALLY EVEN THE OTHER HALF
OCCURRING WHEN OUR CHILDREN ARE
IN THE CARE OF OTHERS AND THE
PROJECT BECAUSE WE HAVE PARENTS
ONE AND WE'LL WORK IN THE
RICHMOND PROGRAMS LIKE SPORTS
AND CULTURAL ACTIVITIES. IN
RECENT YEARS WE HAVE SEEN THE
MEDIA COVERAGE OF THESE
CATASTROPHIC CASES COMING OUT
OF THE SAME ENRICHMENT
ORGANIZATION WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
EARLIER ABOUT THE DIED USING
YOUR DATE COULD OT STICK WHITE
HOUSE IN PENN STATE EACH OF
THESE CASES WERE NOTED WE NOT
ABOUT A SINGLE VICTIM OR
PERPETRATOR ALONE BUT I'LL BE
INTRODUCING THE TRYING TO COVER
UP THE CATASTROPHIC NUMBER OF
VICTIMS WE CANNOT RELY ON
MANDATED REPORTER AND EMPLOYEES
AT THE EXAMPLE OF THE NEED
CASES. BY THE CONVICTION OF.
THOSE SAME EMPLOYEES EDITORS
WILL PROTECT BY. INSTITUTION
LET THE SEXUAL ABUSE OF CHILD
OF CHILDREN. AND MANY THOSE
CHILDREN COULD HAVE BEEN. IF
MORE OVERSIGHT HAVE BEEN GIVEN
THE NEED IS. AND THEIR- OR HOW
INSTRUCTORS. WE NEED MORE FOR.
AND MORE TRAINING JUST LIKE
THIS BILL PROPOSES. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU. MODERATE
WILL GO BACK TO JUST WITNESSES
STATING YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION OR POSITION THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CAITLYN JENNER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LINE
THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUBS IN
SUPPORT. Q. MISTER JERRY HAVE
NO NELSON Q. THIS TIME WILL
GIVE ANOTHER SECOND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
ALL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE OH SIX. RIGHT NOW WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION IN THE SAME
PROTOCOLS WILL BE AFFORDED.
WILL ALLOW THREE MINUTES FOR
PRIMARY WITNESS AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO WITNESSES PRESENT HERE IN
THE ROOM OR TWENTY FORTY AND
INTO THE FALL MARKED.
MODERATORS ANY PRIMARY WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION- AB FIVE OR. SIX
GOOD MORNING THERE- THANK YOU-
THIS IS KATHY SURE FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION- WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE- THE AUTHOR
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS WITH
REGARD TO- MANDATORY REPORTING-
I BELIEVE THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENT NOT TO ROAD TO MAKE
VOLUNTEERS- MANDATED REPORTERS
WE WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE OUR
OPPOSITION NINETY WHEN YOU GO
TO OUR INTERNAL PROCESS BEFORE-
WE CAN OFFICIALLY. SAY THAT BUT
AGAIN- WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS- HI HEARING ARE OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL AND
EXPECTED. OPPOSITION YOU CAN
CALL. THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AN- OPPOSITION OR
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION WANT TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME. UNDER
PRIMARY OPPOSITION. HI YES THE
MORNING SHARON BONNER CARD TO
HANNAH AND THE DIRECTING
ATTORNEY OF THE CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS PROJECT A COUPLE PUBLIC
COUNCIL AND WE ALSO A BANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ- AND
WOULD NO LONGER OPPOSED WITH
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT. YOU
KNOW WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
WITH MANDATE REPORTING IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE SEE IN
OUR WORK- WHERE FAMILIES ARE
REALLY SUBJECTED TO SOME
REPORTS THAT ARE UNNECESSARY.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
INCREASING NUMBER THE POOL OF
REPORTERS WOULD BENEFIT
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA. THAT WE
TRULY THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FOR LISTENING TO OUR
CONCERNS. ABOUT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU.
MODERATORS ARE IN HOTELS IN Q.
AS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION IF NOT WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE HEARING
OR. WITNESS LINE SHOULD BE OPEN
SIR. PARK BEFORE WE GO THERE
WILL GO TO COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE PRESENT
HERE AND FORTY TWO ALL THREE
THAT'S IN OPPOSITION OF FIVE OH
SIX. SHE NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE EITHER
MODERATE WILL GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINE AND SEE IF WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AB
FIVE OH SIX TO ASSIST TESTIFIED
STATING YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IN A POSITION. THANK YOU AND IF
THERE IS- OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE
ZERO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HAVE A LINE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THE LINE NUMBER. BY
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LUCY SALCEDO CARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT- WE HAVE BEEN IN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
WITH THE BILL HAS IMPRINTED BUT
WILL TAKE THE- AMENDMENTS BACK
FOR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THIS. NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME TO GIVE
IT ANOTHER FEW SECONDS TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE OH SIX. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU NOW WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE THERE IS THERE
ANY. ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO
EIGHTY FIVE OH SIX. WELL LET ME
GO ON RECORD AND SAY FIRST
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WARMING TO
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS AND
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL. AS
INDIVIDU SPENT SIXTEEN YEARS OF
MY LIFE PRIOR TO COMING HERE AS
A FOOTBALL COACH AND A BASEBALL
COACH ON ANY GIVEN DAY I MIGHT
BE RUNNING LATE AND I WOULD
HAVE A PARENT WHO JUMPED IN
AND- GOT MY PRACTICE STARTED
FOR ME OR OR I WAS RUNNING A
DRILL. AND I NEEDED ADDITIONAL
HAND. APPEARANCE BOARDS JUST
SOMEONE IN A PARK MIGHT JUST
JUMP OUT AND ASSIST ME WITH
THIS AND I WAS TRULY CONCERNED
THAT IT WOULD DISSUADE AND
DISCOURAGE. INDIVIDUALS WHO
JUST MIGHT. BE THE- SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT HELP THEIR
SON OR DAUGHTER ON ANY GIVEN
DAY SO I APPRECIATE THE MOMENTS
THAT YOU'RE- TAKING- REWARDING
THEM FROM HAVING TO BE A-
MANDATORY REPORTER. I'M JUST
CURIOUS AS IT RELATES TO THE
TRAINING AGAIN- OTHER QUOTES ON
ANY GIVEN DAY YOU MIGHT HAVE
SOMEONE VOLUNTEERS SO HOW DO
YOU JUDGE IF THEY VOLUNTEER
FIRST. NUMBER OF HOURS IF YOU
KNOW WHICH ONE DAY THEY MIGHT.
pWOULD THEY STILL HAVE TO TAKE
THE TRAINING IF THEY DON'T KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE
VOLUNTEERING FOR. WHAT IS IT
THIRTY TWO HOURS YOU SAID OR
SIXTEEN HOURS. TOTAL FIXED. THE
REQUIREMENT IS FOR REGULAR
VOLUNTEER SO THE SITUATION THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING EVEN BEFORE
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD HAVE NEVER
KICKED IN- THAT REQUIREMENT IT
WOULD REQUIRE SIXTEEN HOURS IN
A MONTH OR THIRTY TWO HOURS IN
A YEAR. THOSE AREN'T ARM STEP
IN VOLUNTEERS. I WOULD SUGGEST
THOUGH HOWEVER THAT WE SHOULD
REALLY THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT AS A PARENT WHEN I'M
SENDING MY CHILDREN TO AN
ACTIVITY. I'M HOPEFUL THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WATCHING MY
CHILDREN ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
VETTED IN FACT I WAS SHOCKED TO
FIND OUT HOW MANY SITUATIONS
THAT WE LEAVE OUR CHILDREN.
WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVEN'T
BEEN VETTED IN SO YOU KNOW I. I
UNDERSTAND THE KIND OF AYE I'M
RUNNING HALF AN HOUR LATE AND
ANOTHER PARENT STEPS IN- BUT
QUITE FRANKLY I THINK IF WE
WANT TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT
STOPPING. CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ABUSE AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
TOWARDS OUR CHILDREN AND
LEAVING THEM IN THE CARE OF
PEOPLE WE KNOW AND TRUST THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE- STRINGENT ON WHO'S DOING
THE SPONSORING. THAT THAT'S
JUST. A PARENTS RIO AND THAT'S
HOW I APPROACH THIS- AGAIN I
WAS SHOCKED TO FIND A LOT OF
THINGS OUT IN THIS BILL THAT
OUR SUNDAY SCHOOL TEACHERS ARE
YOU KNOW- THE FOLKS WHO ARE
TAKING YOUR KIDS ON FIELD TRIPS
UP FROM SCHOOL NONE OF THEM ARE
VETTED- SO IF. IF SOMEBODY
WANTS TO VOLUNTEER ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND USUALLY IF YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO IS
DOING SO BECAUSE THEY ARE
ACTING AS A PREDATOR IN SOME
WAY- IT'S USUALLY NOT THE
PERSON WHO STEPS AND SO I THINK
THE SIXTEEN HOUR KIND OF. TAKES
CARE OF THAT SIXTEEN HOURS A
WEEK IS A LOT OF VOLUNTEER- IN
A MONTH AND THIRTY TWO AND
HERE'S A LOT OF VOLUNTEER
HOURS. I AGREE M. MY USER I.
TOTALLY GET THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES THAT YOU'VE SET UP
YOUR ON THIS BILL. AND I THINK
WE'VE ALL HAVE ENOUGH EXAMPLES
OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS NON
MAINLY. MUCH LARGER THAT WE'VE
ENTRUSTED AND HAVE HAD A
REPUTATION THAT HAS. YOU KNOW
FAR EXCEEDED. OUR EXPECTATIONS
OF NARAL LEARNING- THE LOVE THE.
DEGREE OF- CHILD ABUSE OF
SIKKIM PLACE AND SOME OF THE-
WHAT WE CONSIDER. ORGANIZATIONS
I'M- AGREE WHERE YOU GO AND I.
UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE- A MEMBER
AND YOUR- OPPOSED TO MEN ARE. I
THINK OKAY AND MOVING THIS BILL
SO I GUESS WE'RE SEEKING A WELL
WOULD YOU- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER. I'M AND I APPRECIATE IT
CHAIRMAN- I APPRECIATE. HABEEN
THIS OPPORTUNITY I DEAL WITH
THE OPPOSITION I DO WANT TO
SUGGEST THOUGH IT IS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO SAY ARE MANDATORY
REPORTERS SYSTEM IS BROKEN THE
TRUTH IS I DON'T CARE IF IT'S
10% OF KIDS THAT ARE FOUND ON
THAT THEY'RE BEING ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED. THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
10% OF KIDS THAT WE NEED TO
REACH AND SO IF THE PROBLEM IS
WITH THE CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
YES BY ALL MEANS LET'S HIRE
FIRST OF ALL I THINK A LOT OF
IT IS WE JUST DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH- WORKERS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY INVESTIGATING THESE
CLAIMS AND ALSO THE PERCENTAGES
THAT THEY USE AS THE REASONING
FOR WHY THIS ISN'T WORKING
ISN'T ACCURATE WE ALL KNOW
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE NETFLIX
SERIES RIGHT. UNFORTUNATELY
SOMEBODY SENT OUT TO THREE FOUR
TIMES BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION
FIND SOMETHING AND A LOT OF
TIMES THEY DON'T FIND OUT UNTIL
THE CHILD HAS DIED SO. I THINK
WE NEED TO BE VERY- AWARE THAT
THAT YES MAYBE WE'RE HAVING
SOME DISPARITIES IN THE WAY
FAMILIES ARE TREATED THAT IS A
PROBLEM IT YOU KNOW INHERENT
BIAS IS A PROBLEM. BUT THE REAL
PROBLEM IS CHILDREN WHO ARE
ABUSED NEGLECTED AND SUFFER
FROM I'M CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ABUSE
THAT WE'RE NOT CATCHING AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA MAKE THE SYSTEM
BETTER BY JUST SAYING WELL WE
DON'T WANNA DO MANDATORY
REPORTERS ANYMORE SO I JUST
IT'S A JUST A FAIR WARNING MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS NEXT YEAR ON THAT PIECE
OF IT. I JUST THINK IT'S VERY
DANGEROUS FOR US TO- DECIDED
THAT IT'S NOT PORTENT UP TO
PROTECT. CHILDREN WITH THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE TODAY. THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER WE HAVE EIGHT TO PASS
AS AMENDED OR. OKAY AS AS
AMENDED AND- CANCEL PLEASE SAW
CALL THE ROLL ON MAYBE FIVE OR
SIX. AB FIVE OF SIXTY PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD PARK ROAD FOR DIET
CHAU BOGUE I SHOVEL GUY COM
LONGER TO SKINNER. SKINNER I
WINNE WINNER BY THE MEASURE
HAS FOUR VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
CONGRATULATIONS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO. SB SIX OH THREE I
DON'T SEE. R. G. YOU- WHEN WE
OPEN THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND WHILE THOSE
MEMBERS WHO WERE ABSENT OUT ON
IT THE STOCK. AB ARKANSAS ON
CONSENT WE OUT OF OUR AB SIX
SEVEN THREE BY A SETTLEMENT
SALAS RICHARDS ON CONSENT. THIS
ED CONSENT CALENDAR SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER
AYE FIVE VOTES BUT MEASURES OUT
FIVE ZERO. THAT'S THE CONCERN
GALLAGHER.
MCCARTY WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY ON YOUR BILL AB SIX
AUTHOR. IT IS HEREBY MISTER
CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH US THIS
THIS BILL IS A MEASURE. FRANKLY
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY FOR- PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SETTLEMENTS AND JUDGMENTS FOR
POLICE MISCONDUCT AND EXCESSIVE
FORCE. WE KNOW WHEN THESE
THINGS HAPPEN THEY'RE NOT JUST
MORALLY WRONG FOR OUR COMMUNITY
BUT THEY COST TAXPAYERS DEARLY
IN IN YOUR OWN- CITY MISTER
CHAIR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
FOR THE ADJACENT CITY T. I
BELIEVE. IN THE CITY AT THE
CITY OF LA ACTUALLY ASKED TO
ISSUE BONDS FROM WALL STREET TO
PAY THESE JUDGMENTS AND SO THIS
HAS A BIG IMPACT ON OUR PUBLIC.
DOLLARS AND MONEY THAT COULD BE
SPENT ELSEWHERE THIS JUST MAKE
SURE THE PUBLIC KNOWS ON ANNUAL
BASIS- WHEN THESE DOLLARS ARE
PAID OUT- RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE I HAVE TO WITH THIS IS
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL
PROVIDE THEM- A TOTAL OF FOUR
MANAGEMENT APIECE SO AT.
WHENEVER WHO'S EVER READY
FIRST- MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP THE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
YEAH. BORDERLINES YOU SHOULD BE
OPEN THROUGHOUT THE CONFERENCE
CALL MODERATOR- OR WITNESSES TO
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE YOU
SURE THE AIRLINE SHOULD BE OPEN
AT THEY'VE DIALED IN AS
WITNESSES NOT GET IT SO I'M
JUST ASKING- SEE IF THEY'RE
READY TO GO. THE NEW YORK WHO
HAD TO OUR MERRY WITNESSES
ARMIDA IN OF ARTISTS ARE EITHER
OF THEM ONLINE HERE. MCCARTY DO
YOU KNOW YOUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE. YES WE HAVE
TI<c.cyan> OF OUR GUESTS WITH AN</c>
INITIATE JUSTICE AND PROFESSOR
SCHWARTZ FROM UCLA. OKAY- ARE
EITHER ONE OF YOU ARE CONNECTED
PLEASE LET ME ASSURE LINES AND
GO AHEAD. YOUR FIRST ADDRESS
ADDRESS PROFESSOR SCHWARTZ
COULD YOU PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE FEATURE ON YOUR PHONE WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO HEAR YOU. MS
VARGAS OF YOUR ONLINE COULD YOU
GO AHEAD PLEASE. SKIP. MY
APOLOGIES WE DO HAVE- MISHRA
PROFESSOR SCHWARTZ LINE- ON BUT
WE'RE NOT GETTING ANY RESPONSE
FROM HER- MS VARGAS YOUR LINE
IS ALSO OPEN CAN YOU CHECK YOUR
MUTE FEATURE. WATER FIGURING
THIS OUT LET'S COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WHOSE. IN SUPPORT ARGUS
YOU'RE LYING SHOULD BE OPEN UP
THE CHECK THAT. OKAY THANK YOU-
MEDICARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PLANO VARGAS I'M THE FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
INITIATE ACCESS. WHEN HE
ACCEPTED AND- INTO AN AMERICAN
CORPORATION BY ACTIVATING THE
POLITICAL POWER OF THOSE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY IT AND WE
ARE IN SHOCK REPORT AB SIX OH
THREE- WE ADVOCATE FOR A POLICY
CHANGE PRICE SPONSORING
LEGISLATION CAMPAIGNING GREAT
STATE BALLOT INITIATIVES. AND
LEADING TO CAMPAIGN TO ENSURE
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION LINE WITH
OUR GOAL AND WE BELIEVE THAT
EIGHTY SIX OH THREE IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP TOWARDS
TRANSPARENCY OF POLICE
MISCONDUCT AND EMPOWER MANAGE
OF THE- THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH EIGHTY SIX OH
THREE SENATORS WILL BE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT- CURRENT
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH AND HOW
THEIR TAX MONEY IS BEING SPENT.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT WITH MORE
TRANSPARENCY CITIZENS ARE
GIVEN- AN INCREASE OPPORTUNITY
TO HOLD LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACCOUNTABLE- ALSO WE WANT TO
REITERATE THAT POLICE
MISCONDUCT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT BLACK PEOPLE. WOMEN
TRANS AND NON BINARY FOLKS AND
BECAUSE EXCESSIVE FORCE AND
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT IN THE FIRST
AND SECOND MOST REPORTED
COMPLAINTS. AGAINST POLICE
OFFICERS WE ARE IN ATHENS.
BUDGETING FOR GENDER AND RACIAL
POLICE VIOLENCE IN OUR STATES
IT IS OUR HOPE THAT EMPOWERING
PEOPLE WITH THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE SETTLEMENT WILL PUSH FOR
GREATER REFORM ACT FOR ITS ANTI
CREASE MISCONDUCT CASES. WE'RE
ASKING FOR YOUR. SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
PROFESSORS WITH YET YES HELLO
LOOK AT THANK YOU MANY BUT-
BEGIN. HELLO WAITING FOR YOUR
TEST THIS. YEAH THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JOANNA SCHWARTZ I AM A
LAW PROFESSOR AT UCLA SCHOOL OF
LAW AND MY RESEARCH HAS
EXAMINED HOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BUDGET FOR AND PAID SETTLEMENTS
AND JUDGMENTS AND POLICE
MISCONDUCT. AS WELL AS THE
LESSONS THAT STATE AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CAN
LEARN FROM THE- I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX
OF THREE WHICH REQUIRES. CITIES
COUNTIES IN THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL PROPOSED
FINANCIAL DETAILS ABOUT POLICE
MISCONDUCT SETTLEMENTS AND
JUDGMENTS ON THEIR WEBSITE.
IT'S OFTEN SAID THAT YOU CANNOT
MANAGE WHAT YOU DO NOT MEASURE.
REQUIRING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
REPORT ON PAY OUT IN THESE
CASES MAY HELP THEM BEGIN TO
LEARN FROM THEM. BOTH ONE
PERSON AGENCIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY PAY LITTLE ATTENTION TO
INFORMATION IN THE LAWSUIT
BROUGHT AGAINST THEM AND THEIR
OFFICERS. CASES ARE DEFENDED BY
CITY ATTORNEYS. THE MONEY TO
RESOLVE THE CASES ARE PAID FROM
GENERAL FUND. AND LITTLE EFFORT
IS MADE TO KEEP TRACK OF WHICH
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN NAMED AS
DEFENDANTS THE NATURE OF THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST. THEM OR
THE CASE'S OUTCOME. WHAT
STUDIED POLICE LAW PAY IN A
ONE. ACROSS COUNTRY I FOUND
EIGHTEEN OF THE LARGEST CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAD STUDIED. NO
RECORD IN ANY GOVERNMENT AGENCY
OUR OFFICE REFLECTING HOW MUCH
THEY SPENT IN THE LAWSUIT
INVOLVING POLICE IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CAN LEARN
A LOT LOTS OF DATA IF THEY PAID
ATTENTION TO IT. IN MADISON FOR
EXAMPLE CLOSE LAWSUIT FILED ARE
USED TO IDENTIFY RISKY BEHAVIOR
AND THOSE FINDINGS. I ARE USED
TO REDUCE DANGERS IN MEDICAL
PRACTICE. IT ALSO WELL
ESTABLISHED THAT REQUIRING
ORGANIZATIONS AND GOVERNMENT TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR BEHAVIOR IS A KEY TOOL OF
REGULATION. FEDERAL SECURITIES
LAWS REQUIRE DISCLOSURE
INFORMATION TO CONSUMERS LAWS
REQUIRE CORPORATIONS TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
USE OF CHEMICAL WORKPLACE.
INJURY AND NUTRITIONAL VALUE.
IT IS REQUIRED. ABOUT APPROVE
BEHAVIOR BOTH THE ORGANIZATION
OF LEARN MORE ABOUT THEIR
CONDUCT AND BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE OF THIS INFORMATION
CREATE PRESSURES TO IMPROVE.
SOURCEBEYOND THESE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
SHOULD ALSO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE THEIR
TAX DOLLARS ARE GOING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE BACK TO
OUR ROOM OVERFLOW ROOM IN
TWENTY FORTY KIDS WHO ARE YES
FOR WITNESSES HERE AND FORTY
TOOL THREE UNLESS SOMEONE'S
COMMENTS IN THE LAST FEW
MINUTES. WE SEE NO ONE AND
TWENTY FORTY WE HAVE NO ONE
HERE FORTY TWO OR THREE
MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND SEE. IF THEY'RE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF SB.
SIX OH THREE. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX OH THREE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
TWENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING CARE
MEMBER EXPRESSED FORGET OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU HAVE. LINE. SIXTEEN
GOOD MORNING LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FORTY.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE FOR
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE NUMBER.
BY TWENTY PARDON ME ONE MOMENT.
FIND TWENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STAND FELIZ AUTO ON BEHALF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
RICHER WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. GIVEN A
CERTAIN SET THERE'S ANYONE KICK.
DESIRING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF. SIX OH THREE. RIGHT NOW
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION- DO WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- AB SIX OLD. THREE
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS EVERY SARGSYAN
CONCLUDED CITIES IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION SB SIX ZERO THREE
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN
JUDGES ASSOCIATION AS MANY AS
97% OF ALL CASES THAT ARE FILED
ARE RESOLVED OTHER THAN BY
TRIAL. MANY OF THESE
RSOLUTIONS ARE SETTLEMENT
WHICH ARE NOT BASED ON
CULPABILITY BUT RATHER ON
WEIGHING THE COSTS AND SETTLING
OUTSIDE OF COURT. POTENTIALLY
HAVING. TO COVER COSTS. HE WE
PUT A LOS OF A LAWSUIT THE
DEFENSE SETTLED WITH THE
PLAINTIFFS BECAUSE IS MORE. TO
USE. AIRPORT POST WITH INCOME
PUBLICLY WITH NOT BETRAY IN.
PICTURE OF WHAT PERSON. AND
CONDUCT ADDITIONALLY THIS
MEASURE INCLUDES NINE
REIMBURSABLE AND POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS STATEWIDE. ADDITIONAL
STAFF RESOURCES AND INFORMATION.
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALITY IMPORT REALLY SETTLEMENT
ON THEIR WEBSITE. EVEN IF THE
COURTS TRANSPARENT ON THE OF
LOS. WE DO HOWEVER CONCERNS
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
FUTURE SETTLEMENT BASED ON THE
INFORMATION. PLEASE REQUEST YOU
KNOW THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DO SO NOTICES AN OPPOSITION
WILL COME TO THE BACK TO THE
ROOM ON. HERE FORTY TWO OR
THREE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX OH THREE.
SHE NINE HOTEL MOVED TO TWENTY
FORTY. THEY'RE STILL ON THERE
AS WELL MODERATOR WILL GO BACK
TO THE PHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX AUTHOR.
IDENTIFIED OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
FOR THE FOR THE OPPOSITION.
GIVEN ANOTHER SECOND OR TWO
JUST TO MAKE SURE. HELLO LINES
INTO SIR THANK YOU NOW WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
AS IT RELATES TO. SB SIX OH
THREE BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE
NEW BARRY. MISTER CARD WHICH
ARE CLOSE THANK YOU ADAM YOU
KNOW THIS I DON'T THINK IS THAT
SUPER COMPLICATED NOR
CONTROVERSIAL IDEAS IT'S ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY LAST YEAR CITY
SACRAMENTO PAID OUT OVER THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN SOME HIGH
PROFILE CASES THEY DID NOT GO
TO COURT THAT'S TRUE BUT WE ALL
SAW WITH OUR OWN TWO EYES THE
MOST NOTABLE WAS THAT STEPHON
CLARK SHOOTING WHERE HE WAS.
GUNNED DOWN AS GRANDMA'S
BACKYARD AND SO THIS JUST
ENSURES THAT THESE PAYOUTS AND
SUPPLEMENTS ARE KNOWN TO THE
PUBLIC ON ANNUAL BASIS SB RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I BELIEVE
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
WHICH- WE HAVE A- LOOKS LOOKING
FOR A MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SPIN MOVE BY
CENTERS- SOONER WIENER. CANCEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A V.
SIX OH THREE SB SIX OH THREE
BRADFORD ON RADFORD I IT CHAU
BUG I TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER
HI I'M LONGER AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE
FIVE ZERO THIS REGARDING YOUR
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO SOME WOMEN. CHIU AND I
SEE HE'S HERE AND HE'S READY TO
GO- HE'S HERE TO PRESERVE. AB
TWELVE FIVE NINE. MORNING
MISTER CHAIR SENATORS ARE AB
TWO NINE SIX TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES WHOLE BY PREVENTING
DEPORTATIONS BASED ON FAULTY
GROUNDS. ALL OF US HAVE HEARD
THE TRAGEDIES OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO AFTER SERVING YEARS IN
PRISON AND PAY THEIR DEBT TO
SOCIETY ARE SUDDENLY
TRANSFERRED TO ICE UPON THEIR
RELEASE. WE DON'T HEAR IS THAT
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE DO NOT
KNOW THAT THE CRIMES THEY WERE
CONVICTED OF REPORTABLE CRIMES.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY SAYS THAT
IF SOMEONE IS ON AWARE OF THE
ADVERSE IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES OF A CHARGE THEN
THAT CONVICTION COULD BE FOUND
TO BE LEGALLY INVALID. A FEW
YEARS AGO IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OR
LEGISLATURE CREATED A PROCESS
FOR INDIVIDUALS ON AWARE OF
THESE IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES
OF THEIR CONVICTION TO PETITION
THE COURT. BUT THAT PROCESS IS
ONLY AVAILABLE TO THOSE
CONVICTED AFTER A PLEA BARGAIN
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE TO THOSE
CONVICTED AFTER TRIAL. I'M OF
THE PERSPECTIVE WE SHOULDN'T-PUNISH PEOPLE FOR PURSUING
TRIALS AND TRYING TO PROVE
THEIR INNOCENCE PEOPLE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO A
TRIAL. THE CONSEQUENCES OF
INVALID CONVICTIONS CAN BE
DEVASTATING FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT INDIVIDUALS TORN FROM
THEIR FAMILIES WHO HAVE THEIR
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP BLOCKED
BASED ON CONVICTIONS. THAT ARE
LEGALLY INVALID. THIS BILL
WOULD SIMPLY EXPAND THE CURRENT
PROCESS TO INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED BY JURY TRIAL SO THAT
THEY CAN PRESENT EVIDENCE TO A
COURT THAT THEY MEANINGFULLY-
THAT THEY FAIL TO MEANINGFULLY
UNDERSTAND IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE AND
TURN IT OVER TO OUR WITNESS.
THANK YOU. MARIE WILL GO TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
WILL PROVIDE A PERFORMANCE OF
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF. AB
TWELVE FIVE NINE BY THEIR
PRIMARY WITNESSES. HELLO HELLO.
YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO HI
MY NAME IS BOTH HI NINE SIXTEEN
YEAR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
RIGHT SPECIALIZED BECAUSE
ELECTION EARLY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU AND YOUR
FELLOW TEAM LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE. AB CHAIR. LET ME BEGIN
BY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON BEHALF AB EIGHT
THIRTEEN AND IT QUICKLY SB
TWENTY EIGHT ON LIVE CREATING
AND CLARIFYING PENAL CODE.
SECTION FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
POINT. AT THE END QUITE LATER
LIKE SAVING THOUSANDS OF THAT
AMOUNT AND WHO WOULD HAVE
EITHER SEPARATELY BALBOA IMPACT.
ON CONNECTION. NOW IT'S KIND OF
THE FINE PAUL LACK FOURTEEN
SEVEN THREE POINT SEVEN AND
EXPAND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHALLENGE OLD ILLEGAL
CONNECTIONS TO ALL PEOPLE
INCLUDING THOSE CONDUCTED BY
TRIAL. ONLY 2% OF PEOPLE ARE
CONVICTED BY TRIAL IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN SMALLER
PERCENTAGE ELIGIBLE CURRENTLY
FUNDED THIS STATUE. I AM
CONFIDENT YOU LIKE. LEAVE THAT
NO KALENJIN PEOPLE NO MATTER
HOW SMALL SHOULD SEPARATE THE
OLD ILLEGAL CONNECTION. IT
INDIVIDUALS LEFT OUT REPRESENT
VERY REAL PEOPLE INCLUDING
BACKGROUND BY FATHER OF THREE
WHO HAS LIVED IN THE UNITED
STATES HAS A GREEN CARD HOLDER
SINCE HE WAS THIRTEEN. ECONOMIC
CURRENTLY IN DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS THE FINANCING
MARIJUANA CONVICTION SIX YEARS
ABOUT THAT CAN BEEN REDUCED TO
A MISDEMEANOR. BUT FOR THE CAT
THAT HE CONVICTED BY JURY TRIAL
THE CRIME WOULD HAVE A CHANCE
TO PRESENT EVIDENCE. THAT HIS
CONVICTION WHAT. STOP COULD BE.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT
POINT FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE
POINT SEVEN HE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT CHANCE. AND IT TAKES A
MANDATORY PERMANENT AND LYFT
KIND SEPARATION PUBLIC FORMALLY.
GOOD CLEAN UP EXAMPLE. THERE IS
NO IN THE STATE. WHICH IS WHY
IT HAS TO DATE GENDER NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS DRAWN
SUPPORT CAN BE A OFFICES
INCLUDING YELLOW SANTA CLARA
SAN FRANCISCO. LOS ANGELES AND
THE ENTIRE PROSECUTORS ARE
LYING. IN ADDITION TO MORE THAN
THIRTY GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS
FROM THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE HOLD WHILE. THANK YOU.
NO WITNESSES WILL MOVE NOW TO-
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
ZERO ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE FIVE NINE GENE NO
ONE HERE WILL MOVE TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL
MODERATOR WILL GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES AND SEE IF THERE'S-
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF TWELVE FIVE NINE.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE TWENTY ONE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
FOUNDER DISADVANTAGED MARTINO
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
THE FINE SIXTEEN. NINE SIXTEEN.
GOOD MORNING LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. PINE. FORTY THREE.
MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS STEPPED
IN ROWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER ALSO IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE THANK YOU.
PINE FORTY TWO. THE MORNING
ANTICODON ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU CAN DOWN STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ACLU'S
CALIFORNIA ACCENT PROUD POST
FUNDS ARE URGING SUPPORT. PINE.
EIGHTEEN GOOD MORNING MRS CHEN
PASSED THE HALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE TWENTY EIGHT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND FULL OF
ALL ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
NINE FORTY FOUR. DANIEL GOOD
CARE ABOUT BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROGRESS BOB
THIS IS A MAJOR. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. GIVEN
THE DURATION OF WHO SECOND TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE DESERVE
SO. PICKING AND SUPPORT. AB
TWELVE FOR NINTH. CORRECT YEAH
WE HAVE ONE MALE TO OPPOSITION
AND WE SEE NO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION LISTED HERE ON THE
BILLS IS THAT STILL THE CASE.
YES- RIGHT SO WILL COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
IS THERE ANYONE DESIRES OF
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE FIVE NINE. C. NINE WILL
LOOK TO ARE OVER OVER FOR A
FULL ROOM CHARGE TO TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS
WELL MODERATOR WILL NOW GO TO
PHONE LINES IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES AND CUTE IS OURS OF
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION. OF
TWELVE FIVE NINE AND NOW IT'S A
TOUGH. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE AB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION OKAY WE'RE GOOD FEW
MORE SECONDS AS MATURE WITH THE
MISSING. ONE RIGHT AWAY- WILL
BRING TO THE COMMITTEE CENTER
SCANNER. THANK YOU CHAIR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE DAY EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION FOR YOU BRING
IN THIS BILL AND I DON'T REALLY
HAVE ANY QUESTION ON IT AND I
AM PREPARED TO MOVE IT AT
WHATEVER POINT PEOPLE ARE.
READY TO ACT ON IT THIS IS
EGGMAN FINAL TIME AS ANY TO
START OKAY LET'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR SKINNER THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS- BY
MEMBERS. I DO WANNA THANK YOU
ARE A SOMEONE CHIU FORTY WHAT I
FEEL IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
THAT PROVIDES. TRUE A- JUSTICE
IN FAIRNESS TO INDIVIDUALS AND
APPELLEE KNOWN A RIGHT AFTER
BEING WRONGFULLY CONVICTED OF A
CRIME WHETHER THEY WANT TO A
JURY OR A PLEA BARGAIN SO I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE IN A THAT'S WHY THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL SO-
WE TALKED CLOSE AT THE START
JUST A PER SHARE GET MISTER
CHAIR AND THE SENATORS AND-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
OKAY CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AB TWELVE R. NINE. AB
WE HAVE TO PASS TO.
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING. AB
TWELVE FIVE NINE BRADFORD. AYE
AT SHOWBOAT NO SO BUT NO
KAMLAGER I AM LONGER AT AYE
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE WIENER.
WIENER I'D VOTERS FOUR TO ONE-
ASSUMING THAT BILLS ALL FOR
THEM CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
CENTERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE BY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO SOME
OF THE BILL TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
TODAY AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
SEEKS TO AMEND THE PENAL CODE
SECTION RELATING TO EXPUNGEMENT
TO SPECIFY THAT THE DISMISSAL
OF A CASE UDER THOSE SECTIONS
WOULD NOT AUTOMATICALLY RELIEVE
A DEFENDANT FROM THE TERM EVENT
UGH UNEXPIRED TENURE CRIMINAL
PROTECTIVE ORDER ISSUED IN THIS
CASE IN THE CASE. ARE THESE TEN
YOUR PROTECTIVE ORDERS ARE ONLY
ISSUED IN CERTAIN SERIOUS CASES
SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
STALKING AND ELDER ABUSE THE
ORDERS PLAY SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
PROTECTING SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE VICTIMS OF A VIOLENT
CRIME CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE
ORDERS ARE NOT PUNITIVE IN
NATURE THEY ARE NON PENAL
RESTRICTIONS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT. CRIME VICTIMS. THE
BILL IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY DOES NOT REQUIRED THAT
PROTECTIVE ORDERS REMAIN IN
PLACE IN ALL CASES EMERITI
PART. PRESERVES JUDICIAL
DISCRETION TO TERMINATE OR
MODIFY AN ORDER DEPENDING ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCE. THE BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
ENJOYS SUPPORT FROM CRIME
VICTIM ADVOCACY GROUPS. TODAY
WITH ME ON THE PHONE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT IS LESLIE KLEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE L. A. COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU PRIMARY
WITNESS PREPARE TO TEST SOME OF
OUR REGION TESTIFY AT THIS
POINT. YES THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M LESLIE KLEIN I'M AN
ASSISTANT HEAD DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE MOST RECENTLY WITH THE
FAMILY VIOLENCE DIVISION WE ARE
THE PROUD SPONSOR AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE. THE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TOOLS USED IN THE PROTECTION OF
VICTIMS OF CRIME PARTICULARLY
IN CASES INVOLVING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND STALKING INTO THE
INTRINSIC ONGOING NATURE OF
THESE RELATIONSHIPS. IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHETHER THE INCIDENT
AMOUNTS TO A MISDEMEANOR OR A
FELONY. ANY ACT OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CAN QUICKLY ESCALATE
INTO A VIOLENT FELONY INCLUDING
ACT OF GUN VIOLENCE. I HAVE
CERTAINLY SEEN IT HAPPEN IN MY
TWENTY SIX YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
THE PROTECTIVE ORDERS GIVE
VICTIMS THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO KEEP THEIR ABUSERS AWAY A
PROTECTIVE ORDER CAN LITERALLY
BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE
AND DEATH. THE BILL WE ARE
PROPOSING DOES NOT ADD ANY MORE
RESTRICTIONS IT SIMPLY
CLARIFIES A BASEMENT IN THE LAW
AS IT CURRENTLY. IS WRITTEN.
FOR TEN ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY AND DISCRETION TO
ISSUE CRIMINAL PROTECTIVE
ORDERS UPON CONVICTION AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STALKING
ELDER ABUSE AND BESTBUY TAX
CRIMES THAT ARE VALID FOR UP TO
TEN YEARS. IMPORTANTLY COURTS
HAVE THE JURISDICTION TO MODIFY
OR TERMINATE THOSE PROTECTIVE
ORDERS WITHIN THE TEN YEARS
THAT THEIR INSURANCE AND
NOTHING IN THIS BILL CHANGES
THAT. THE BILL WE ARE PROPOSING
WHAT AMENDED PENAL CODE SECTION
TWELVE OF THREE POINT FOR
PUBLIC THREE POINT FOR A PUBLIC
THREE POINT FOUR B. AND TWELVE
A THREE POINT FOUR TWO FIVE
WHICH ARE OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
EXPUNGEMENT FACTIONS. CURRENTLY
WHEN A DEFENDANT MOVED TO OR
HAD THE CASE DISMISSED. UNDER
ONE OF THE SECTIONS NOTHING IN
EXISTING LAW ADDRESS IT HOW THE
COURTS SHOULD HANDLE THE ISSUE
AND THE ISSUE OF THE UNEXPIRED
PROTECTIVE ORDER. THIS BILL
CLARIFIED THAT WHEN THEY
DISMANTLE IS GRANTED UNDER ANY
OF THE SECTION A PROTECTIVE
ORDER PRESUMPTIVELY REMAINS
VALID UNTIL ITS EXPIRATION
EXPIRATION DATE FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE VICTIM. WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME GIVING THE
COURTS THE DISCRETION TO MODIFY
OR TERMINATE THE ORDER. IT'S
PRESENTED WITH INFORMATION THAT
WOULD JUSTIFY SUCH ACTION.
CURRENTLY WHEN THIS ISSUE
ARISES IT IS UP TO THE
INDIVIDUAL JUDGE ON HOW HE OR
SHE DECIDES TO HANDLE THE
ISSUE. IT IT IT EVEN ADDRESSED
AT ALL MANY JUDGES WILL APPROVE
THE PROTECTIVE ORDER REMAINING
IN EFFECT. MANY TIMES BUT IT
SHOULD NOT DISCUSSED AT ALL BUT
THE PROTECTIVE ORDER REMAINS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT CHECK THEM
LEAVING A DEFENDANT WITHOUT ANY
INSIGHT THAT HE OR SHE MAY
STILL BE SUBJECT TO THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER. IN OTHER
INSTANCES COURT MAY FEEL THEY
MUST DISMISS THE EXISTING
PROTECT THE BORDER IF THEY
DISMISSED THE CASE. AB EIGHTY
ONE IF THE COURT GUIDANCE ON AT
THE STORY AND PUT THE DEFENDANT
ON NOTICE. HE OR SHE STILL
SUBJECT TO THE ORDER UNLESS AND
UNTIL THE COURT TERMINATE OR
MODIFY THE ORDER. IT FURTHER
AGAINST THE VICTIM THE PEACE OF
MIND TO KNOW THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER IN PLACE. ANY SUGGESTION
THAT A VICTIM COULD SIMPLY GET
A CIVIL RESTRAINING ORDER IF
THEY REALLY WANTED ONE IT'S
FLAWED. NAVIGATING THE COURT
SYSTEM IS DAUNTING TO MOST
LAYPEOPLE IT FORCES THE VICTIM
TO HAVE TO RELIVE THE
ATROCITIES THEY'VE ALREADY
EXPERIENCED WHILE HOPING AND
PRAYING THE JUDGE WILL GRANT
IT. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY AS
EXPRESSED TO ME BY A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR THERE IS A
FEAR THAT GOING BACK TO COURT
YEARS LATER WELL AS SHE PUT IT.
OKAY THE PHARMACY NASTY AND
REFOCUSED. THE ABUSER ON THE
VICTIM. AB EIGHTY HELPS ENSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT
BEHIND TENURE PROTECTIVE ORDER
LOGIC ISN'T PUT IN JEOPARDY BY
ADDRESSING THE VAGUENESS
CURRENTLY FOUND IN THE
EXPUNGEMENT SECTIONS OF THE
PENAL CODE. SECTION I HAVE
NEVER ELIMINATED ALREADY ASHU
TO THE EXIT FOR THE LIMIT.
REPRESENTS TWENTY CENTS
POSSIBLY RIGHT THE TERM TIME.
YES I AM I AM VERY CLOSE TO
THEM IN A- BIG DESPERATE
LIMITED PURPOSE BUDGET
FOLLOWING AN INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
CASE HAS BEEN DISMISSED THE
RIGHT TO SAY THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME WHEN
SUBMITTING A JOB APPLICATION.
BUT THOSE CATS PROTECTION'S
ENCASED BOX HAVE ALSO MADE
CLEAR THAT NOT EVERY CONSEQUENT
ADDED CONVICTION SHOULD GET THE
KERR. THE INDIVIDUAL WHO KILL
BARRED FROM OWNING OR
POSSESSING A FIREARM BUT STILL
REGISTER INSPECTED CENTER AND A
MASSIVE DEAL DISBURSING
CONVICTION THAT THE BIKE IT'S.
RATIONS THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THE COURTS HAVE RECOGNIZED NOT
EVERY SPRINTER AND LIMITATIONS
PENALTY. PROTECTIVE ORDER ARE
NOT AS A KIND OF. FOR THE
DEFENDANT BUT AFTER. FOR THE
VICTIMS WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
WILL MOVE TO. THE HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE YEARS OR ANY
WITNESSES AND- SUPPORT WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF FOR-
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE SHE NO ONE
HERE WILL NOW GO TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL.
NOW WE'LL GO BACK TO OUR PHONE
LINES MODERATOR ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WISHING TO
TESTIFY STATING YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBER AND MICHELLE THOMAS
SHARP REPRESENTING THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. MR WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE SEE WE HAVE A
SHOW YOU LISTED AS A PRIMARY
LEAD IN OPPOSITION. AS THE
INDIVIDUAL REPRESENTING NATIO
YOU PREPARE TO TESTIFY AT THIS
TIME. YES GOOD MORNING M
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS KATHY SURE
FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION- WE
RESPECTFULLY NOT OPPOSE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE. CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS OF
ALLOWING CERTAIN OFFENDERS TO
PUT THEIR RECORD BEHIND THEM
AND MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES BY
ALLOWING THOSE OFFENDERS TO
HAVE THEIR CONVICTIONS EXPUNGED
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WOULD
INSTEAD IN THE LIMITED
CATEGORIES OF CASES WHERE THE
PUNISHMENT IS AVAILABLE KEEP
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
PROTECTIVE ORDERS UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE CRIMINAL
COURT FOR A PERIOD OF UP TO TEN
YEARS SH TO ALLOW THE ORDER TO
REMAIN IN EFFECT. THE KIND OF
CASES IN WHICH SUCH AN ORDER
CAN BE ISSUED INCLUDE NOT ONLY
FELONIES OR CRIMES OF VIOLENCE
THAT ALSO INCLUDE MANY
MISDEMEANORS FOR EXAMPLE ALL
REGISTRABLE FACT. AND
ATTEMPTING- OVER A PROTECTIVE
ORDER CAN BE ISSUED NOT ONLY TO
PROTECT THE VICTIM BUT ALSO IN
SOME CASES PROTECT THE WITNESS.
TO A CRIME COMPLIANCE WITH AN
ORDER THAT REQUIRES STAYING
AWAY FROM AN INDIVIDUAL'S
NEIGHBORS FRIENDS OR FAMILY
MEMBERS MAY POSE A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO THAT PERSON'S
ABILITY TO BE INTEGRATED TO
THE- COMMUNITY. A CALIFORNIA
LAW RECOGNIZES SOME INDIVIDUAL
DESERVE A SECOND CHANCE. TO
START OVER FREE OF THE CONTROL
OF THE CRIMINAL COURT. AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WE DID NINE
MANY INDIVIDUAL PLATFORM.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE BACK TO
THE HEARING ROOM AS ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SHE NINE
WILL GO CHORE OVER FORMER
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL. MODERATOR WILL
NOW GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
IN ITS INVESTORS. WITNESSES ARE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. UGH AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE NOW IS THE TIME.
SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE THE ONE CHEWING
UP IN OPPOSITION TO STOP. WE'LL
GET A FEW MORE SECONDS JUST TO
MAKE SURE. ALL RIGHT WILL BRING
BACK TO YOU MANY TIMES ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER
SERVER COM LONGER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I. JUST HAD A
QUESTION- SO IN NGUYEN V.
EXPUNGEMENT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
CASE IS DISMISSED. ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT PROTECTIVE ORDERS
THAT ALIGN WITH THAT PARTICULAR
CASE ARE WE JUST TALKING ABOUT
PROTECTIVE ORDERS THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN- ISSUED. INDEPENDENT
CORRECT OF THE OF THAT
PARTICULAR CASE THE INTENT IS
FOR- IN THAT PARTICULAR CASE
BUT I DO HAVE OF LESLIE THAT
CAN ANSWER OTHER QUESTIONS ITEM
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT IN THAT
PARTICULAR CASE NOT TO- REMOVE
THE EXPUNGEMENT OR EVEN NOT
ADDRESS THE EXPAND OUR I'M
SORRY THE PROTECTIVE ORDER
DURING THE EXPUNGEMENT. AND
CURRENTLY IT'S NOT ADDRESSED
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIX IT IS NOT EVEN A PART OF.
THE CONVERSATION IF YOU WILL
WHEN THE EXCITEMENT HAPPENS SO
WE'RE TRYING TO BRING IT INTO
THE INTO THE FOREFRONT SO THAT
THE JUDGE HAS THE DISCRETION TO
SAY. WE CAN EXPECT WE CAN
TERMINATE THE PROTECTIVE ORDER
OR- IF IT'S BEING CAPPED AT
LEAST THE VICTIM KNOWS WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THAT PROTECTIVE
ORDER RIGHT NOW IT'S BASICALLY-
IF THE EXPUNGEMENT HAPPENS SOME
SOME FOLKS WILL SAY WELL THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER- GOALS WITH
THAT AND OTHERS. JUDGES SAY IT
DOES NOT SO THERE'S NO CLEAR.
DEFINITION OF WHEN IT DOES. GET
REMOVED OR WHEN IT DOESN'T.
OKAY SO BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE BILL WAS
THAT. EVEN IF THE ONCE THE-
EXPUNGEMENT HAS HAPPENED THAT.
THE UNEXPIRED PROTECTIVE ORDER
STILL CONTINUES UNLESS THE
COURT DECIDES TO MODIFY IT
WHICH IS DIFFERENT FROM. ONCE
THE EXPUNGEMENT HAPPENS THE
UNEXPIRED PROTECTIVE ORDER IS
STILL BROUGHT TO THE COURT FOR
THEM TO MAKE A DECISION SO.
IT'S I MEAN IT'S A DISTINCTION
WITH A DIFFERENCE BECAUSE ON
THE ONE HAND YOU'RE GIVING
AUTHORITY TO THE JUDGE TO SAY
TAKE ALL OF THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION. AND THEN ON THE
OTHER HAND YEAR YOU'RE SAYING
WILL EVERYTHING IS GOING TO
CONTINUE ON LAST YOU
SPECIFICALLY TAKE THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION SO IS IT GOING
THE FORMER FOR THE LATTER WELL.
IF I CAN ASK CLOSELY TO OUR I'M
SORRY. WHY OF. THIS LEAD TO
RESPOND TO THAT PLEASE BECAUSE
I THINK YOU KNOW AGAIN MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT GIVES
THE JUDGE THE DISCRETION TO DO
EITHER RIGHT TO SAY YES OR NO
AND SOME JUDGES ARE CHOOSING
ONE AND OTHERS ARE CHOOSING THE
OTHER AND THAT'S THE REASON FOR
THE- FOR THE BILL. BLACKLICK
YES SOAK SO CURRENTLY IT THE
WAY IT WORKS IS WHEN SOMEBODY
MAKES THEM AN EXPUNGEMENT
EMOTIONS THAT THE RECORD
EXPUNGED. IT'S LITERALLY UP TO
THE JUDGE AND TO WHOEVER'S
MAKING THE MOTION ON WHETHER
THEY WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF THE PROTECTIVE ORDER IF
THERE'S ONE AND QUITE. A LOT WE
ARE PROPOSING IT WOULD MAKE IT
SO THAT. AT THE TIME THAT THE
MOTION TO EXPUNGE IT MADE. THE
PERSON MAKING IT CAN. BRING UP
THE ISSUE OF THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER. AND ASK THE COURT TO
MODIFY OR TERMINATE. BUT IF IT
DOES NOT ADDRESS- BROUGHT UP BY
THE PERSON WHO IS MAKING THE
MOTION ON BEHALF OF THE
DEFENDANT. AND THE PRESUMPTION
WOULD BE THAT THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER WOULD REMAIN IN FULL
FORCE AND EFFECT. I'M NOT AND
UNTIL SOMEBODY BRINGS THAT.
PROTECTIVE ORDER TO THE COURT
AND THE COURT HEARS WHATEVER
EVIDENCE STATE HAS BROUGHT
FORWARD TO MAKE THE
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER IT IS
APPROPRIATE OR NOT APPROPRIATE
TO TERMINATE. EFFECTIVE ORDER.
ITS WAY THE DEFENDANT IS ON
NOTICE- WHEN YOU MAKE THE
MOTION TO EXPUNGE THAT THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER WILL REMAIN IN
FULL FORCE AND EFFECT. THE SAME
WAY HE CAN'T OWN A GUN IS ON
NOTICE. REMAINS IN FULL FORCE
AND EFFECT. AND THAT DAY. TO
ABIDE BY THAT PROTECT ORDER AND
AT THE VICTIM WILL THEN STILL
BE PROTECTED. AGAIN I'M LOCKED
INTEL. EVIDENTLY BROUGHT
FORWARD THAT JUSTIFIED THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT
CONFUSED ME BECAUSE- IT IT
SOUNDED LIKE YOU WERE SAYING IN
THE BEGINNING THE IT WAS A LONG
SENTENCE BUT IT SOUNDED LIKE
THE FIRST PART OF THE SENTENCE
SAID THAT AT THE TIME THAT THE
EXPUNGEMENT IS HAPPENING THAT
DEFENDANT'S COUNSEL. CAN THEN
ALSO BRING UP THE ISSUE OF THE
UNEXPIRED PROTECTIVE ORDER TO
ASK THAT IT BE MODIFIED BUT
THEN IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE
SECOND PART OF WHAT YOU SAID
SAID THAT AT THE TIME OF THE
EXPUNGEMENT THE UNEXPIRED
PROTECTIVE ORDER WOULD STILL BE%
IN A FACT UNLESS AND UNTIL
SOMEONE BROUGHT ADDITIONAL
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT THAT
UNEXPIRED PROTECTIVE ORDER
COULD THEN. BE EXPIRED SO. ARE
THOSE AT THE SO ABILITY. LET
THAT MAYBE I CAN TRY TO EXPLAIN
IT WHEN THAT MOTION IS MADE
UNDER THE AS WE ARE PROPOSING
IT. IF NOBODY DISCUSSES IT
NOBODY BRINGS UP THE ISSUE OF
THE PROTECTIVE ORDER AT THE
TIME THE EXPUNGEMENT MADE. THIS
LOT WOULD KEEP THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER PRESUMPTIVELY IN PLACE.
THAT DOESN'T PRECLUDE SOMEBODY
FROM BRINGING UP THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER AND ASKING THAT IT BE
MODIFIED OR TERMINATED AT THE
SAME TIME AS- THE EXPUNGEMENT.
BUT AS WE ARE PROPOSING IT. IT
WOULD KEEP THE PROTECTIVE ORDER
IN PLACE. AT THE TIME THAT THE
CONFINEMENT PRESUMPTIVELY AND
LAST SOMEBODY AFFIRMATIVELY ASK
THE COURT OR THE COURT ON ITS
OWN MOTION DECIDES THAT IT
WANTS YOUR BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
TERMINATED BUT THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. YES IT DOES IT BUT IT
BRINGS ME BACK TO I GUESS MY
ORIGINAL QUESTION WHICH WAS
WHETHER OR NOT THE PROTECTIVE
ORDER ALIGNED WITH THE
PARTICULAR CASE AND SO IF A
CASE HAS BEEN EXPUNGED IN THE
PRESUMPTION OR ASSUMPTION S
THAT- IF YOU FIND. THERE'S NO
MORE DERELICTION WITH THE
PARTICULAR DEFENDANT BECAUSE OF
THAT PARTICULAR CASE AND WHY
WOULD YOU HAVE A PROTECTIVE
ORDER IN PLACE- FOR A CASE THAT
HAS BEEN- DISMISSED OR
EXPUNGED. BUT I THAT'S NOT YOU
KNOW ABOUT. YOU DON'T ADDRESS
THAT OR WOULD YOU LIKE DOWNTURN
YEAH. D. D. EXPUNGEMENT. ABOUT
LAWS. OUR THE WAY THEY WORK IS
THAT IF SOMEBODY HAS HAS- MET
THE STANDARDS FOR COMPLETING
THEIR PROBATION. EIGHT THE CASE
AUTOMATICALLY IS ENTITLED TO BE
EXPUNGED IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF THE VICTIM BEING
PROTECTED SO WHILE THERE THEY
MAY HAVE MET ALL THE GUIDELINES
AND STANDARDS THAT THEY NEEDED
TO FOR PROBATION IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY ADDRESS THE
PROTECTION OF THE VICTIM NOT
EVERYTHING OKAY GET A TENURE
PROTECTIVE ORDER. SO IT REALLY
THE TENURE PROTECTIVE ORDERS GO
WITH THE MOST SERIOUS MOLD MOST
VIOLENT CASES THAT ADDS A LOT
THAT CHANGE WHEN T COMES TO-
PROTECTIVE JIMMY TO
EXPUNGEMENT. IT MADE IT EASIER
TO GET A CASE EXPUNGED BUT WE
HAVEN'T ADDRESSED THE ISSUE-
THE PROTECTIVE ORDERS AND WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN TO THEM AT THE
TIME OF THE EXPUNGEMENT. SO
THERE'S INCONSISTENCIES IN THE
WAY THE LAWS HAVE DEVELOPED BUT
A LOT THAT HAS REALLY ADDRESSED
THE FACT THAT DICKENS WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED FOR THE SAFETY
OF THE VICTIMS. AND THE
PROTECTIVE ORDERS THEY DON'T.
ENTER THE DEFENDANT ACCEPTED
THAT THEY PREVENT THEM FROM
BEING IN CONTACT WITH THE
VICTIMS WHO ARE AFRAID TO
INTERFERE AT. THE AT THE
DEFENDANT'S. SENATE SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I
THINK BY I APPRECIATE- SENATOR
TOM WORKERS QUESTIONS BECAUSE
WHEN OUR TO STAND THAT IT'S-
THE PRESUMPTION IS THAT THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER WILL CONTINUE
UNDER THIS LAW UNLESS AT THE
SAME TIME DEEP. CHORDS
PROCESSING THE EXPUNGEMENT THAT
THE ENTITY ASKING FOR THE
EXPUNGEMENT ALSO ASKS FOR A
LIFTING OF THE PROTECTIVE ORDER
AT WHICH TIME THE WHOLE
DISCUSSION CAN TAKE PLACE AS TO
WHETHER THAT PROTECTIVE ORDER
STILL NEEDED BUT IF THE
INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT. ASK FOR
THE PROTECTIVE ORDER TO BE
LIFTED IT WOULD CONTINUE SO MY
QUESTION AND ASSUMING THAT I'VE
ACCURATELY WHO WERE IN THE IN
MY OWN- LAYPERSON WAY. I'D
DESCRIBE THIS MAN MY QUESTION
WOULD BE IS THERE ANYTHING IN
THE LAW AS PROPOSED THAT WOULD.
GIVE SO I FIND THE LAWYER
ASKING FOR THE PROCESSING THE
EXPUNGEMENT I ALSO ASK FOR THE
REMOVAL OF THE PROTECTIVE ORDER
IS THERE ANYTHING IN THE WAY
THIS LAWS WRITTEN THAT WOULD.
FURTHER HINDER THE ABILITY FOR
THE- PROTECTIVE ORDER TO BE
LEFT SOON OTHER WORDS IS IT
WOULD STILL ALLOW THE SAME KIND
OF PROCESS THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
IN ANY ARE. COURT DISCUSSION
AROUND LIFTING SUCH AN ORDER OR
IS THERE SOMETHING IN THIS BILL
THAT WOULD FURTHER RESTRICT.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NOTHING
FURTHER THAT WOULD RESTRICT IT
SO IF YOU HAD A SITUATION WHERE
THE ATTORNEY WENT AND MADE THE
MOTION TO EXPAND AND AT THE
SAME TIME ASK THE COURT TO
MODIFY OR TERMINATE PROTECTIVE
ORDER. THEN THE JUDGE WOULD
HEAR THE INFORMATION AND MAKE
AN ASSESSMENT BASED ON THE CASE
AND THE FACT AND ANY ANY
EVIDENCE THEY WERE WILLING TO
TAKE OR HERE ON WIDE AND
PROTECT THE BORDER SHOULD OR
SHOULD NOT BE TERMINATED SO NO
IT DOESN'T. PUT ANY FURTHER
LIMITATIONS ON THE ABILITY. TO
MODIFY OR TERMINATE THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER. ALL RIGHT I
APPRECIATE. THE CLARIFICATIONS
AND- AND COMFORTABLE. OUT WITH
THE WITH THE BILL THANK YOUNG
BOY AND IF I MAY- MISTER CHAIR
PROTECTIVE ORDERS ARE USUALLY
OR- TENURE PROTECTIVE ORDERS
ARE ISSUED IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES ELDER ABUSE AND SEXUAL UP
SIX TO SEXUAL ABUSE NOTHING
ELSE SOLD YOU KNOW TYPICAL
RESTRAINING ORDERS CAN GO
ANYWHERE DEPENDING ON THE JUDGE
FROM ONE YEAR TO FIVE YEARS IS
USUALLY THE MAXIMUM IF THAT
THAT OFFENDER AND I HAVE
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT AT THE
OFFENDER COMES BACK. AND IS
TAKEN BACK TO COURT AND IF ON A
REGULAR RESTRAINING ORDER THAT
THE JUDGE WOULD RE ISSUE THIS
TIME A FIVE YEAR MOST OF THE
TIME A FIVE YEAR RESTRAINING
ORDER BECAUSE THEY VIOLATED THE
FIRST ONE THOSE ARE THE REGULAR
RESTRAINING ORDERS PROTECTIVE
ORDERS ARE USUALLY AGAIN WITH
THE MESSAGE FIVE SEVERE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ELDER ABUSE
AND SEXUAL ABUSE OF A TEN YEAR
IS DIFFERENT THAN A REGULAR
RESTRAINING. ORDER IF THAT
MAKES ANY SENSE. I ANY FURTHER.
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS HERE-
THANK YOU FOR THIS MEASURE BUT
I TO AMONG LOW CONFUSION OR SO
THEN WHEN I STARTED AS A
RELIGIOUS MEASURE BECAUSE-
AGAIN OUT BY WHAT'S BEING
DESCRIBED SEEMS LIKE WAS
ALREADY IN PLACE I THOUGHT THE
JUDGE ALREADY HAD THE
DISCRETION TO. AT THE TIME OF
THE EXPUNGEMENT DETERMINE IF A
PROTECTIVE ORDER SHOULD
CONTINUE OR NOT SO. I'M REALLY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
ADDITIONAL FORTY DOES THE COURT
HAVE WHERE THAT. PERSON WHO'S
JUST HIT THEIR- RECORD
EXPUNGED- I THINK A CENTER
COMMA GRASS AND ARTS CENTER-
SKINNER OUSTED IN PETER-
PREVENT THE INDIVIDUAL FROM-
GETTING THERE BOB LIPS IS
RESTRAINING ORDER LIFTED OR
PROTECT WATER REMOVED AND IS IT
THIS IMPEDED ANY WHEN YOU SAID
NO OR YOUR WHAT THE SAID NO SO
I'M JUST. REALLY TRYING TO SEE
WHAT'S DEFAULT TO ME THE WAY IT
WORKS IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT IT IS
FOR ME PERSONALLY IT'S ABOUT
THE VICTIM BUT IT'S ALSO A TO
HELP- THE PERSON THAT'S BEING-
YOU KNOW THAT'S IN FRONT OF THE
JUDGE BECAUSE IF THERE IS NO-
IF THEY DON'T MENTION IT. THE
JUDGE OR ANYBODY ELSE MENTIONED
THAT THEN THE PROTECTIVE ORDER
IS STILL IN PLACE FOR THE TEN
YEARS SO IF YOU'RE SOMEBODY
THAT HAVE BEEN REHABILITATED
AND HAS DONE EVERYTHING AND YOU
KNOW HAVE SEEN THE LIGHT FOR IT
IF YOU WILL THEN THEN THAT
PROTECTIVE ORDER REMAINS IN
PLACE. FOR THE TEN YEARS
REGARDLESS SO THIS IN MY
OPINION GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT PERSON TO ALSO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT I'VE LEARNED I'VE
DONE WHAT I CAN YOU KNOW THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER IS NO LONGER
IN PLACE AND THAT GIVES THE
JUDGE THE AUTHORITY THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND IT SO IT'S- IT IS
ABOUT THE VICTIMS FOR ME BUT
IT'S ALSO FOR THOSE FOLKS BACK.
IF IT'S NOT MENTIONED THEN THAT
IF NOT ADDRESSED IN THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER IS IN PLACE
FOR THE TEN YEARS WITHOUT IT
AND THEN LATER THEY WOULD HAVE
TO COME BACK AND SAY HEY THAT
REMOVE THE PROTECTIVE ORDER I'M
JUST CURIOUS ON WHY WOULDN'T I
INDIVIDUAL I JUST GOT MY RECORD
EXPUNGED AND I KNOW I HAVE THIS
FOR. RESTRAINING OR PROTECTIVE
ORDER THAT STILL HANGS OVER MY
IT WHY WOULDN'T I US AT THE
TIME IT DEPENDS ON THE ATTORNEY
SOMETIMES BUT YOU KNOW
ATTORNEYS YOU KNOW YOU HAD SOME
FOLKS HAVE BETTER ATTORNEYS AND
OTHER IN MY OPINION AND IF I AN
ATTORNEY'S JUST IN AND OUT
TRYING TO JUST FINISH THIS AND
DOESN'T PAY ATTENTION TO THAT
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT
HAPPENS THEN THOSE. FOLKS DON'T.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION- ANY. DECISION
COME ON BUT THIS REQUIRE THE
JUDGE TO DECLARE THAT AS
SOMETHING FOR THE DEFENSE TO
RAISE UP. SO THE ONUS IS ON ON
THE COURT. I MEAN IF IT IF YOU
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING THIS WOULD
STILL BE IN PLACE AND THAT THE
COUNCIL WOULD STILL HAVE TO.
ASK FOR CONSIDERATION FOR THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER TO BE
CONSIDERED THIS DOESN'T DECLARE
THAT IN THE EVENT OF AN
EXPUNGEMENT THAT THE COURT THEN
NOTIFIES THE COUNCIL THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN DO I
MEAN I THINK THAT WOULD BE MORE
HELPFUL THAN SORT OF CONTINUING
WITH AN ASSUMPTION. THAT
COUNCIL HAS TO. MAKE THIS ASK.
BUT MAYBE I'M I MEAN ARE NOT. I
AGREE BECAUSE I'M I MEAN I
WOULDN'T SEE WHY COUNCIL
WOULDN'T IF YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
CLIENT THAT HAS. RETURNED TO
WORK ON IT WHY WOULD YOU ASK
THEM IN REGARDS ARE MANY CASES
YOU'RE DOING. THAT'S PART OF
THE PROCEDURE OF. CLEARING THIS
PERSON RIGHT OR WHY WOULD YOU
ASK FOR THAT THAT'S PART I'M
KIND OF LOS. THANK YOU BYE. YOU
KNOW I THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS A
GOOD MEASURE AND BEEN WORKING
ON IT HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ON THE OTHER HOUSE BY TARA YOU
KNOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND IF YOU SEE FIT
THAT THERE'S ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SUGGEST I WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THOSE AND WORK
WITH YOU ON HOW TO FIX IT TO
THIS FOR IT TO BE SOMETHING
THAT- YOU ARE COMFORTABLE WITH-
IF IT GOES FURTHER. THANK YOU.
WE'RE SPEAKING MOTION. FOR THIS
MEASURE WELL BE ONE OF MOVE THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATORS
SKINNER. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON TWELVE EIGHTY ONE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD DODD SHOBO AYE PROVOKE
AYE COM LONGER. KAMLAGER NOT
VOTING SKINNER HI IN OUR I
WINNER WINNER ICE FOUR ZERO
MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES YOU'RE
OUT THANK YOU. OUR LAST ITEM IS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHARLES IT
IS. AB. THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
FLUID TO OUR HOUSEKEEPING.
SOMEONE SHOW YOU WILL BE ABLE
TO. PROVIDE YOUR PRESENTATION
ON YOUR MEASURE. YEAH SENATORS
ARE AB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
SERVES AS AN EFFECTIVE FIRST
STEP IN ADDRESSING THE GROWTH
OF THE HACKED DATA MARKETPLACE
BY MAKING CLEAR THAT NO ONE CAN
KNOWINGLY SELL PURCHASE OR
UTILIZE HACKED DATA TODAY WE
LIVE IN A DIGITALLY CONNECTED
WORLD WHERE MORE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET THAN
EVER BEFORE. FURTHER AND MET
THE PANDEMIC INTERNET ACCESS
HAS QUICKLY BECOME A BASIC
NECESSITY FOR ALL ASPECTS OF
LIFE HOWEVER AS MORE PEOPLE USE
COMPUTERS AND THE INTERNET
CRIMINALS HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITY
I HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
HACK INTO INFORMATION IN THE
FIRST HALF OF TWENTY NINETEEN
IN FACT DATA BREACHES EXPOSED
FOUR POINT ONE BILLION RECORDS
HERE IN THE FIRST HALF OF
TWENTY TWENTY. ODD THIRTY SIX
BILLION RECORDS WERE EXPOSED
THESE TYPES OF A CYBER CRIMES
RANGE FROM BREAKING INTO ONE
COMPUTER NETWORK TO STEALING
FINANCIAL INFORMATION TO OTHER
CLIENTS SUCH AS CORPORATE
ESPIONAGE. FRAUD AND EXTORTION.
CARRILLO COOPER. COMPUTER
HACKING AND STEALING
INFORMATION IN ALL FORMS
NEVERTHELESS SOME COMPANIES
HAVE SEIZED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TURN A PROFIT BY SELLING DATA-
OBTAINED ORIGINALLY BY THE
HACKERS FOR EXAMPLE THE NEWS
RECENTLY REPORTED ON A COMPANY
THAT SELLS ACCESS TO BREACHED
PERSONAL DATA INCLUDING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AS A STATE THAT IS
HOME TO SOME OF THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE LAWS PROTECTING
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS AND
WITH THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY IS
ENSHRINED IN OUR CONSTITUTION.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD LEAD THE WAY
IN STOPPING THE RISE OF A
HACKED DATA MARKETPLACE AB
THIRTEEN A ONE WILL MAKE IT
UNLAWFUL FOR A PERSON TO SELL
PURCHASE OR UTILIZED DATA AS
DEFINED AS THE PERSON KNOWS OR
REASONABLY SHOULD KNOW IS
COMPROMISED DATA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IDOLS. THANK YOU-
WE SEE WE HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT TO
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY- ARE THEY PREPARED TO
TESTIFY AT THIS POINT. OPERATOR
THE ONLINE. TO A LONG PLACE.
WHERE IS MORRELL NO DOESN'T
APPEAR WE HAVE- THEY WE HAVE
HERE IS CHAU MUHAMMAD AND I'M
NOT. ONLINE. INDICATION IS THAT
HE VERY IN PERSON. ALL RIGHTS
SHOW- ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE AND NINE CHAMBER WHOSE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIRTY
ONE ME THIRTEEN NINETY ONE.
KERN SEEN ON WILL GO TO A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL. MISTER MODERATOR
CAN WE GO THROUGH PHONE LINES
INTO THIRDS WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FIFTY CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY NOW LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
LISTED AS OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYONE ONLINE- WHAT WE HAVE IN
PERSON OKAY WE ARE WITNESSING
PERSON TO TESTIFY. CAN YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
EUROPE THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU
JOHN MEMBERS FROM ALL OVER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
WE RESPECTFULLY ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED TO AB THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE AND WE ARE WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE AUTHOR ON
AMENDMENTS. WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAU
AND STUFF HARD WORKING TIME
WORKING TOGETHER WITH US ON
THIS BILL BUDGET BY WITH A
BACKDROP FOR SEEKING AN
OPERATIONAL MORE OF A TECHNICAL
OPERATIONAL ALLOWANCE FOR CYBER
SECURITY AND IDENTITY THEFT
PURPOSES. OUR CONCERN IS JUST
THAT IF IT TOO BROAD-
PROHIBITION APPLIES- THEN THE
ABILITY TO THE ABILITY TO USE
OR ACCESS DATA BUSINESS- SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN WAS OBTAINED
PURSUANT TO COMMISSION OF A
CRIME IT COULD LIMIT THE
ABILITY FOR SOME BUSINESSES-
AND OTHER GOOD ACTORS TO USE
OR- OTHERWISE ACCESS DATA FOR
LEGITIMATE PURPOSES SO. WE ARE
ENGAGED WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE- WE HAVE SHARED
AMENDMENTS- TO HELP RESOLVE
THESE CONCERNS AND WE SINCERELY
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SHE NINE NOW WILL MOVE
CHORE OVER FLOOR ROOM A TWENTY
FORTY OTHER WITNESSES IS THERE
ARE NO MODERATOR KNOWLEDGE GO
TO FALL MARGIN SHIFT OR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE- THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN
IN Q. THIS TIME. WHO NOW WILL-
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO THIS
MEASURE CENTER CARE. ARE EARNED
A SEMI RETARDED YOU DISCUSS THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU ARE TAKING.
YES ABSOLUTELY- I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE CHAMBER PRESENTED
THREE AMENDMENTS- WE HAVE
ALREADY ACCEPTED ONE. INDIA TWO
IS STILL TRYING TO NARROW THE
SCOPE OF IT THE SCENARIO THAT
WAS DESCRIBED BY THE CHAMBERS-
A LEGITIMATE ONE I THINK THE
STATE IS THE EXAMPLE THAT GAVE
WAS. OF SCANNING SCANNING THE
DARK WEB FOR THE- FOR
INFORMATION THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BENEFIT CLIENTS FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK THAT DOESN'T
REALLY GOT VISIT REALLY FALL
UNDER THE AMBIT OF THIS
PROPOSED LAW TO IT TO BEGIN
WITH. BUT I'M I'M DEFINITELY
WILLING TO LOOK AT THAT
PARTICLAR SITUATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LANGUAGE IS THERE
TO- YOU KNOW- ACCOMMODATE OUT I
THINK I THINK THAT'S A
LEGITIMACY EDUCATION ACT YEAH
THEY'RE DOING LEGITIMATE THINGS
THROUGH YOU KNOW SO. AS PART OF
THEIR POWER OPERATION I THINK
BUT WITH THE SAME TIME WE DON'T
WANT TO CREATE EXCEPTIONS THAT
HARD TO THE SO LARGE THAT WOULD
KIND OF BEAT UP THE ROOTS SO TO
SPEAK. SO ON THE INTENT IS TO
NARROW THE AMENDMENTS SOMEONE
SO THAT WE COULD TELL YA HI
ACCEPTED SO I GUESS IT YEAH OF
THE THREE WARY ACCEPTED ONE. SO
WE STILL WORKING ON NARROWING.
THE SCOPE OF THE DEAL THE TWO
PIECES. BUT I DO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SAID IN A CITY. THAT THERE
ACCOUNT WITH. SPECIAL SOON CHAU
CANNOT BE CLEAR THAT YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED THE TO THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS PUT FORTH- TO PUT
A CIVIL REMEDY IN THE BILL
SINCE UNLAWFUL IS UNCLEAR. AND
TO CLARIFY THAT THIS IS NOT
APPLIED TO THE PRESS. ARE
REWORKING LANGUAGE CURRENTLY IN
THE BILL. YES TOTALLY YES
ACTUALLY GOT. AND USED. TAKEN
ONE OF THE THREE CHAMBER
AMENDMENTS ARE CORRECT CORRECT.
I HAVE A QUESTION US SENATOR
TROUBLED WITH REGARDS TO THE
PROCEDIMIENTO HAVING ACCESS TO
THIS INFORMATION OR SELLING OR
PURCHASING THIS INFORMATION. MY
UNDERSTANDING ON THE AMENDMENT
REGARDING THE PRESS IS THE
AUTHOR ALREADY INTENDED TO MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT THEY COULD USE IT
FOR PUBLIC REASONS BUT- THE- ST
PIERRE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DRAFTING ON THE WAY IT WAS AND
JUST WANTS TO FLIP THE LANGUAGE
AROUND. I'M SORRY WHO WANTS TO
FLIP THE- CALIFORNIA PRESS THE-
SAN PA WANTED THE LANGUAGE TO
BE CLEARER. SO INSTEAD OF RIGHT
NOW IT READS. IT'S COULD BE
READ TO BE LIMITED BY THE BAR
NICKY CASE AND INSTEAD MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT THE PRESS IS USE OF
THIS INFORMATION. FOR PUBLIC
GOOD COULD BE USED. THAT WE
TALK ABOUT REARRANGING THE
SENTENCE A LITTLE BIT SO THAT
YOU KNOW SUPPORT A PARTICULAR
WORD GETS IN FRONT OF ANOTHER
WORD SO WE ARE ACCEPTED NOT TO
SO THIS IS IN CONNECTION WITH
APPOINT A KEY CASE CORRECT
TELL. TO I THINK THE KEY TO A
YOU KNOW THE FOKKER PRESS FOLKS
ARE FINE WITH THAT. THE YEAH WE
ARE ACCEPTING. AND ON TOP OF
THAT THE THREE AMENDMENTS SET
TO OR WHAT PROPOSED BY THE
CHAMBER AYE WE ACCEPTED ONE SO
FAR. AND THEN WE STILL WORKING-ON THE AT THE OTHER TWO JUST A
TO NARROW THE SCOPE BUT I DO
UNDERSTAND AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE-
ISSUE. DEFINITELY. THERE. I
WOULD BE MORE COMFORTABLE WITH
THE AMENDMENT THAT. REGARDING
THE- IT'S SPECIFIC THE
LANGUAGES- REGARDING THE IT
NIKKI VERSUS PROPER CASE AND-
NOT LIMITING BE PROVIDING OR
OBTAINING DATA IN AN OTHERWISE
LAWFUL MANNER FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PROTECTING COMPUTER SYSTEM
OR DATA STORED IN A COMPUTER
SYSTEM OR PROTECTING AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM RISK OF
IDENTITY OR FRAUD. I WOULD BE
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT AND
I'M NOT SURE WHY I GUESS-
DECEMBER TWO I'M NOT SURE WHAT.
I DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE OPPOSITION TO THAT
AMENDMENT IS- IT'S SENATOR- D.
CONCERN THAT I HAVE WITH T. E.
SECOND PIECE OF WRITING THE
FIRST PIECES ALREADY OKAY I
MEAN I THINK UP UNTIL HE
FINALLY THE SECOND PIECE DEALS
WITH- DOES NOT LIMIT DOES NOT
LIMIT PROVIDING OR OBTAINING
DATA IN. AN OTHERWISE LAWFUL
MANNER FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROTECTING A COMPUTER SYSTEM
WHAT DATA IS STORED IN THE
COMPUTER SYSTEM OR IT'S THE
LATTER PART OF PROTECTING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM RISK OF
IDENTITY THEFT WITH THE FRAUD I
THINK IT IS THE LATTER PART OF
THE SENTENCE AT DEAD TONIGHT
YOU KNOW I LIKE TO KIND OF KNOW
A LITTLE BIT COM ON. SO I THINK
THE WORDS IDENTITY THEFT OR
FRAUD I THINK COULD BE NARAL
DELIBERATE EVEN MORE I THINK
I'M OKAY WITH YOU KNOW THE ON
THE FIRST PART OF THE SENTENCE
BUT THE STOP TO LET YOU KNOW
THE- SECOND PART OF IT I THINK
WE CAN KIND OF. FINE TUNE A
LITTLE BIT I THINK SO TELL ME
WHAT THE ISSUES ARE FROM YOUR
POINT OF VIEW OF WHY. WE
WOULDN'T WANT TO PROTECT. D. S.
INDIVIDUAL FROM RISK IDENTITY
THEFT OR FRAUD. IN OTHER WORDS
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THAT'S
PERHAPS TOO BROAD I THINK I
THINK THE FOR THE WAR FRAUD
ITSELF OR IDENTITY THEFT. COULD
BE CONSTRUED. ARE A LITTLE BIT
TOO BROADLY- I THINK. IT MAY BE
BROADER THAN THE SCENARIO THAT
THEY ARE ENCOUNTERING WHICH IS
LIKE I SAID. THEIR SITUATION IS
SAYS IN HIS ATTY WOULD LIKE TO
STAND THE DARK WEB FOR ANY
POTENTIAL LEAKAGE OF FOSS ARE
LET'S SAY INFORMATION. SO THAT
THEY COULD RELATE THAT
INFORMATION TO THEIR CLIENTS
WHICH IS A TOTALLY LEGITIMATE.
OPERATIONAL ROCEDURE. WHICH
COULD BE NARROWER THAN YOU KNOW
THE IDENTITY THEFT OR FRAUD. SO
I'M HOPING TO EAT YOU KNOW THE
COULD USE A DIFFERENT
TERMINOLOGY. TO DESCRIBE THE
SITUATION SO WE GOT A I'LL BE
TOTALLY FINE SO. IT'S THOSE
THREE WORDS I GUESS THAT THAT
THAT WE COULD KINDA NARAL A
LITTLE BIT MORE. OKAY YEAH BUT
AS FAR AS THE FOR THE OF
FORMER. PART OF THE SENTENCE I
THINK I'M ALL FINE I THINK- THE
BILL. I MEAN IT WAS ALREADY
COME UP WITH. THIS BILL NOW
WOULD GO TO A PROBE CISA NO NOT
IT WOULD GO STRAIGHT TO THE
FLOOR. OKAY HI- CHAIRED THE
HEAD DID- I WONDERED IF- YOU
AND COMMITTEE STAFF HAD TALKED
ABOUT. THOSE ON TWO WORDS.
EXACTLY.
I'M SUPER JEWS
EXACTLY- PASS THROUGH THE
MOMENTS AND CLARIFYING AGAIN
YOU'D TAKEN A TWO OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I'M AND I GUESS
THE WORD SMITHING THAT YOU'RE
DOING AS RELATES TO FRAUD I'M
AND I TO. NOW LORENA PLAY ONE
ON TV I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT THE ISSUE
IS HERE- BUT DTT ISSUE IS THAT-
THE CHAMBER IS PROPOSING THIS
PARTICULAR SET OF AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS A PARTICULAR SITUATION
THAT THE- HEALTH. WHICH IS THE
SCANNING OF THE DARK WEB FOR
INFORMATION PERTAINING TO THEIR
CLIENT AND THEY LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO STAND CONTINUE SCANNING THE
WEB FOR DARK THE DARK WEB FOR
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY COULD
RELATE THAT INFORMATION TO THE
CLIENT AS PART OF THEIR
CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIP OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE. ZERO
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IS TO
PROPOSE THIS PARTICULAR A
SENTENCE HERE TO ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR SITUATION WHICH I
THINK THE UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
YOUR OBJECTION TO THAT I THINK
THAT'S COMMONSENSE. A REQUEST
THERE I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT YOUR OBJECTION TO THAT
YEAH WHAT THE OBJECTION IS. THE
THREE WORDS COULD BE CONSTRUED
MORE BROADLY THAN THAT
PARTICULAR SITUATION THAT WAS
MY CONCERN SO I'M TRYING TO
THINK OF A WORD OF WORDS THAT
WOULD. EVEN NARROWER IS A
LITTLE NARROW SO THAT IT COULD
COVER DESPERATE SITUATION AND
NOT TRY TO CREATE AN EXCEPTION
THAT'S BROUGHT YOU KNOW TO
BROUGHT TO BASICALLY EAT UP THE
RULE. SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE CONCERN I MEAN. I
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO DO THE
LAW TO BE. TWO BROAD NUMBER ONE
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I WON A
COMEDY PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
ILLEGITIMATE THINGS SO THAT'S
THE DEAL GOT TO FIND FIVE
DOLLARS I'M TRYING TO CREATE
HERE. BUT IF WE CANNOT COME UP
WITH THE BETTER TERMINOLOGY
BETWEEN NOW AND APPROACH I
THINK YOU KNOW ALL- YOU'RE
GOING TO APPROACH. I'M SORRY I
TO FLOOR WE STILL HAVE TO
ACTUALLY TO AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
AND THAT IS TO CREATE A REMEDY
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT DOES NOT CREATE CRIME TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY WE WILL DO
THE DOES TOO. SO WE STILL NEED
TO AMEND THE BILL SO TO SPEAK.
AND YOU CAN TO PUT THE
AMENDMENT IN THERE. SO I THINK
WE'RE 90% THERE MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS- AND. YOU KNOW. I
JUST WANT TO. PUT LANGUAGE
TURNED THERE TO ACCOUNTS FOR
THAT BUT- SAID. TO ACCOMMODATE
THEIR THEY'RE ALL YOU KNOW.
TOTALLY LAWFUL. THE. IT HERE IF
THE COMMITTEE IS WILLING TO
SUGGEST LANGUAGE BETWEEN NOW
AND THE FLOOR- ALL GAME. SO
LET'S BE CLEAR. YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE WORD FRAUD.
FRAUD AND IDENTITY THEFT CITING
BRO ONE WE LEAVE IDENTITY THEFT
AND THEN TAKE FRAUD OUT- THAT'S
PROBABLY BETTER. YEAH WITH THAT.
OKAY WITH YOU CENTERS GONNA. I
MEAN IF NOT WERE PROPOSING
HOLDING THIS AND CONTINUE WORK
ON BEFORE WE LET IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE SO IT JUST SEEMS
STILL A WORK IN PROGRESS SO WE
HAVEN'T COME TO A REAL
AGREEMENT ON AN- I THINK WE'RE
90% OR 95% THEIR CELL. I'M
SORRY I THINK WE'RE 90% THERE I
MEAN AS FAR AS BUILDING
COMPLETE CONSENSUS SO. SO
YOU'RE GOOD WITH REMOVING THE
WORD FRAUD AND EVEN IDENTITY
TOOK THAT OFF AND THEN. WITH
THE CHAMBERS AMENDMENTS AND
THEN THE TWO THAT WE ARE
PROPOSED HERE AND MY- HEARING
THAT CORRECTLY YEAH HE
ESSENTIALLY OKAY- SENATOR CAN I
LET ME JUST VERIFY TO CAN YOU
CLARIFY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT.
YOU'RE A CIVIL REMEDY YOU
INTEND TO PUT IN AS- THERE WERE
TWO CHOICES I THINK ONE WAS TO
REFER TO- BE IN P. SEVENTEEN
TWO HUNDRED. WHICH HAS BEEN
ADDRESSING THE ANALYSIS THE
OTHER IS TO ALLOW THE COURT TO-
GRANT INJECTIONS IF THEY SO
DESIRE. ON AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING AMENDMENTS IN
COMMITTEE WHICH AMENDMENT ARE
YOU SUGGESTING YOU'RE TAKING
ALL THE OF THE LATTER OKAY THE
LATTER WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL NOT
CREATE NEW CRIME. OKAY YES YEAH
I THINK THAT'S THE INTENT I
MEAN I. DON'T WANT TO CREATE
NEW CRIME IF I COULD AVOID IT-
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YEAH COMMITTEE I WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT I ONLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. BECAUSE IF
THERE WERE AMENDMENTS OUTSIDE
OF WHAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED. I'M
NOT SURE WHERE THOSE WOULD
HAPPEN AND SO I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER WE ARE LANDING ON
WHATEVER THE MEMBERS ARE NOW R
WHETHER. WE SHOULD HOLD FOR A
WEEK IN ORDER TO LAND SO THAT
WERE VOTING ON A BILL THAT CAN
GO TO THE FLOOR. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION THE CONSULTANT WOULD
GIVEN THE QUESTION YOU JUST
STASHED. THAT CLARIFIED WHICH
CIVIL CODE SECTION WAS BEING
MODIFIED. OR I DO WANNA
SUMMARIZE THEIR MOMENTS AS I
UNDERSTAND THEM YES PLEASE OKAY
SO. THE N. UNLAWFUL BE DEFINED
THAT HIS STAFF ASSEMBLY
LANGUAGE REGARDING A CIVIL
INJUNCTION- ENFORCED BY THE- A
DA OR AN ATTORNEY GENERAL'S MY
UNDERSTANDING- THEN. WE ARE
GOING TO FIX THE LANGUAGE PUT
THE LANGUAGE AROUND REGARDING
THE PRESSES RIGHT TO ACCESS AND
WE WILL TAKE THE CHAMBER
AMENDMENT IN D. MINUS THE WORD
OR FRAUD. THE WORDS ARE FRAUD.
COULD WE NOT HOLD THIS MEASURE
UNTIL NEXT WEEK AND GET THE ALL
CLEAR FAR TOO I THINK ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO BE A LOT
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THE-
MEASURE. WE CAN DO THAT WE HAVE
YEAH BILLS BUT WE CAN I WOULD I
WOULD PROPOSE THAT WEEK KID.
THIRTY ON WERE GOING HERE AND
IS HOLDS MEASURE OVER UNTIL
NEXT WEEK. TO WHICH CAN GET A
COMPLETE AGREEMENT ON OVER HERE
ARE ALSO JUST. I'VE HEARD ME IT.
I THINK JUST TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE BECAUSE FOR ME IT'S
HARD TO ENVISION. THAT CHANGE
CALCULATIONS WHEN WE'RE MAKING
THESE KINDS OF AMENDMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU KNOW ON THE
YOU KNOW HERE IN COMMITTEE- SO
I WOULD BE OKAY WITH THAT
BECAUSE AS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IT AND ACTUALLY
BECOMES MORE CONFUSING TO ME. I
MEAN MY UNDER I ALWAYS THOUGHT
THAT IT WAS. ILLEGAL TO DO ALL
OF THESE THINGS ANYWAY TO SELL
DATA I MEAN IT'S ILLEGAL TO
HAPPEN TO SOMEONE SYSTEM INTO
LEGAL TO SELL SOMEONE FOR PRIDE
JERRY INFORMATION. YEAH IT IS
UNDER THE LAW UNDER THIS BILL
WHICH STRUCTURE TRYING TO
CREATE SOME OF THOSE
EXCEPTIONS- I GUESS FROM TO
ACCOMMODATE LAWFUL ACTIVITIES-
AND WHICH IS ONE OF WHICH IS
BROUGHT UP BY THE CHAMBER SO
YEAH IT IS IT SHOULD BE ILLEGAL
AND TO SELL AND TO BUY DATA
THAT'S BEEN HACKED WE'RE
LOOKING ACTUALLY AT THE- THE
THIRD PARTY PEOPLE THESE ARE
THE DOWNSTREAM PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO CONTINUE SELLING THE DATA
DATE YOU KNOW THAT'S BEEN
HACKED AND SOLD. SO IT IS A
MARKET PLACE OUT THERE THAT WE
WANT TO STOP SO- SO TELL ME
THIS. YEAR- YOU KNOW. ARM WE
ALL HAVE JUST BECOME. YOU KNOW
BITS OF DATA AND CODES AND
INFORMATION. AND THERE ARE
EITHER ALGORITHMS OR COMPANIES
THAT ARE. TAKING OUR DATA THAT
WE'RE FREELY GIVING EVERY TIME
WE CLICK A BUTTON OR MAKE A
PURCHASE SIX CETERA. I DON'T
NECESSARILY KNOW WHO OWNS THAT
BUT THERE ARE COMPANIES THAT
THEN COLLECT VAST AND THEN SELL
THEM TO OTHER COMPANIES THAT
USE THAT DATA TO THEN CONTINUE
TO MARKET TO US TO SELL US
THINGS. IS NOT DARK WEB
ACTIVITY BUT HOW WOULD THIS
IMPACT THAT BECAUSE COULD YOU
THEN ENTER DOWN YOU KNOW ENTER
INTO DISCUSSIONS ABOUT IF THAT
IS LAWFUL OR NOT BECAUSE THAT.
I MEAN THAT IS USING DATA THAT
YOU HAVE AN EXPLICITLY
AUTHORIZED SOMEONE TO USE AND
IT IS BEING COMPILED- AND SOLD
OR SHARED. TO COMPANIES OTHER
THAN USING IT. NUMBER SO HOW
DOES THIS IMPACT THE VAST WITH
THIS MAKE THOSE KINDS OF
EXCHANGES UNLAWFUL. FOR A FEW
YEARS AGO IT HAS THE- HISTORIC
CITY PA THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH WOULD BASICALLY GIVE THE
CONSUMER THE RIGHT TO. YOU KNOW
SAY YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO KNOW WHAT DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED FROM YOU AND
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO SAY NO TO
PEOPLE SELLING YOUR INFORMATION
ASSURING YOUR INFORMATION. AND
THEN A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE ALSO
PASSED A LAW REGARDING DATA
BROKERS SO WE ARE BASICALLY
PROHIBITING YOU KNOW THE DARK
WEB- YOU. FOLKS IN SELLING OR
MAKING PER. OF THE INTO. THAT
YOU KNOW THAT'S A- ILLEGALLY.
AND THIS IS JUST TO CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE. TO SO- CURRENTLY IT
IS ILLEGAL TO HACK INTO
SOMEBODY'S. COMPUTER FOR DATA
FOR EXAMPLE SO THAT'S ALREADY
COVERED UNDER ANOTHER CODE
SECTION. BUT THE DATA THAT HAS
BEEN CALLED. HACKED INTO AND
SOUL SUBSEQUENTLY FURTHER
DOWNSTREAM. AND THAT'S NOT.
ILLEGAL INDUCTEE OF THE LAW IS
SILENT ON DOT SUIT THIS BILL
WILL BASICALLY CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE BY SAYING LOOK IF
YOU'RE DOWNSTREAM FOLKS WHO
OBTAIN THE HACKED INFORMATION
HE SHOULD NOT. RESELL IT OR YOU
SHOULD NOT PURCHASE WE SHOULD
NOT SELL OR USE IT. SO WE'RE
TRYING TO KIND OF. YOU KNOW OF
SOLVE THE PROBLEM FROM
DIFFERENT ANGLES TO MAKE SURE
THAT KIND WE WEED OUT THE YOU
KNOW THE ILLEGAL ORDERS YOU
KNOW THAT. THESE PEOPLE OUT
THERE. I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU.
WELL I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
HARNESS THE DARK WEB I THINK
THAT'S LIKE THE INTENT OF THE
DARK WEB. WELL I MEAN IT'S IT
HAS A GOOD QUESTION BUT YET
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S A QUESTION
THAT REALLY- DESERVES A LITTLE
MORE DISCUSSION AND LOOKING
INTO- YOU KNOW THE DARK WHERE
WEB IS THE DARK WEB I MEAN I
THINK- BUT- IN. WHICH TRYING TO
FIX THE PROBLEM AS MUCH AS WE
CAN- BUT BUT IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION WHERE THE CHAMBER
BROUGHT OUT. OF THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING DOUBTS OF.
WITHIN THE BOUNDS OF YOU KNOW
LET'S SAY IF A NATION THAT THEY
OBTAIN OUT THERE WHICH YOU KNOW
COULD COULD BE POTENTIALLY
AFFECT I GUESS I YOU KNOW SO.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO FIX ALL THE
PROBLEMS OF THE SO WE HAVE TO
KIND OF DO IT ONE YOU KNOW ONE
PIECE AT A TIME SO- TO THAT'S
THE INTENT I MEAN SO THIS IS A
VERY MODEST BILL INTO TO BEGIN
WITH. I THINK THIS IS OUR THAT
WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BECAUSE I THINK- IT'S STILL A
LOT OF. QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
AS RELATES TO THE BILL AS IT IS
TODAY AND WHERE WE ARE ON A
LANDING. THOSE SAID AMENDMENTS
AND GETTING BETTER CLARITY AS
TO. WHAT THE BILL'S. REAL
INTENT TO SELL ARTISANAL
OBJECTION WILL HOLD THOSE OFF
TILL. NEXT WEEK. L. OKAY SOUNDS
GOOD TO US IN OUR SKINNER. I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK- I
THINK WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I THINK MUCH OF
WHAT'S BEEN ARTICULATED BUT IT
IS HELPFUL FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
SEE IT JUST BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
GO TO ANY OTHER COMMITTEE SO-
AND I THINK THE- SUGGESTION. OF
REMOVING FRAUD. IS A GOOD ONE
AND YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH SO
BUT AT LEAST IT ALLOWS US TO
SEE IT BEFORE WE ACTUALLY DOOR
FOR ME TO VOTE. SO PRECIADO. I
TRY. YOUR FINE WITH THAT AS
CHAU THE FORTY WORKING WITH
YOU- IN A COUPLE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING WORKING ON
THIS MATTER TWO WE CAN BRING IT
TO A POINT WHERE MEMBERS ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH I GET A RIGHT
ERRORS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO LIFTING THE CALL ON
THOSE OUTSTANDING ITEMS SO.
COUNCIL ON WHEN YOU'RE READY
YOU CAN LOOK CALL ON THOSE
MEASURES ARE STILL SUFFICIENT
VOTE AB THREE THREE ONE JONES
SAWYER VOTE IS CURRENTLY FOUR
TWO ZERO SKINNER. SKINNER AYE.
FIVE TWO ZERO. BOB AB THREE
THREE ONE OUT FIVE ZERO. YEAH
AB FOUR ONE NINE DAVIES-
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
COMMA EVER. IT'S ITEM THREE AB
FOUR ONE NINE. COMMA I SKINNER
SKINNER I'D FIVE TWO ZERO AB
FOUR NINE TEEN IS OUT FIVE ZERO.
AB FIVE OH SIX- GONZALEZ DO
PASSES AMENDED TODAY- SHE TOOK
OUT ALL THE MANDATED REPORTERS
THEY'RE STILL GONNA HAVE TO DO
TRAINING BUT NOT BE MANDATED
REPORTERS THE VOLUNTEERS WITH
MORE THAN SIXTEEN. OR THIRTY
TWO HOURS WILL BE TRAINING BUT-
NOT MANDATED REPORTERS AND
SHE'S FIXING THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS SO IT'S D. O. J. AND-
PALM LAGER. OKAY SO YOU'RE OVER
EIGHTEEN. AND YOU VOLUNTEER FOR
MORE THAN SIXTEEN HOURS. IN A
MONTH OR THIRTY TWO HOURS A
YEAR YOU'LL BE REQUIRED TO DO
THE TRAINING AND GET A
BACKGROUND CHECK. BUT NOT BE
AMENDED REPORT. OUR YOU NEED
THAT UNDER EXISTING LAW
ORGANIZATIONS CAN ALREADY
REQUIRE THEIR VOLUNTEERS TO
DEMAND A REPORTER SO ANYBODY
UNDER THAT TIME- WOOD THE
ORGANIZATIONS COULD STILL
REQUIRE IT FOR THEM IT JUST
WOULDN'T BE. REQUIRED UNDER THE
LAW- SOME COME AUGUST. KAMLAGER
ONLINE VOTES FIVE ZERO. AB FIVE
OH SIX IS OUT FIVE ZERO. AND
THAT IS IT. WE WILL CHANGE THIS
CENTER COMMERCE DESERVES A
ALREADY. YOU ALREADY CALLED IT
OUT I THINK SO WE CAN'T CHANGE
THEM OUT. ON. ONE AB TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE IS THAT THE ONE.
THANK YOU. I CAN I. YEAH YOU'RE
YOU'RE DOWN IS NOT VOTING SO
YOU'RE NOT DOWN AS A NOTE SO
OKAY THANKS. PICTURE THE THAT'S
ALL I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE ABLE- ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO. THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE OR VISIT THE
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AN OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
WE WANT TO THANK YOU THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED TWO
DAYS OF GENDER GENDER OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND WE NOW STAND
ADJOURNED.